so we have our next 3x3 up and I can
already tell who this is this is the
most male anime fan generic list ever
not a single romance or or Slice of Life
men men Boys Boys
Boys welcome back to another episode of
trash taste I'm Conor once again joined
by the boys Joan G did you say epode
epode of TR taste it's one of those days
where we all said yeah we're ready and
then you started talking and I'm like
wait oh yeah I just said yes we're
recording now sorry it's uh this is the
first recording after the New Year's my
brain she really looked dead I I think I
look dead too it's this is not going to
be coming out just after New Year so
it's going to be a little bit delayed
but uh this is for the record I've just
time gated this episode G you should be
excited cuz we're talking about your
favorite thing on the planet genin
impact shut the up we're talking about
that the other thing what's the we're
talking about your favorite thing you
mean Joey no we're talking about anime
okay it's our it's our monthly or bonly
anime episode uh and uh we're going to
be doing another 3x3 but we're not just
going to be doing a regular 3x3 cuz
we've done that before in the past
instead we're going to be judging other
people's 3x3 more specifically we asked
a bunch of our guests our previous
guests on trash taste to send in their
anime 3x3 and we're going to be judging
their good or bad tastes in anime uh we
didn't get everybody's 33 cuz some of
them guests haven't watched anime y uh
and some that have haven't watched
enough anime like Pete and Chris yeah uh
so the people that we have or the guests
that have submitted their 3x3 are
Charlie daus Emily kah Kevin muden
shindell Sydney and I guess Las beam is
also included okay um this uh this
should be interesting uh I always like
3x3 because you can normally get a gauge
of someone's personality and taste just
by seeing like a view of their 3x3 so I
think it'll be a fun game before it's
revealed who the
3X3 uh that we're judging is that we
have a guess of uh who that person is
based on our like get a get a quick
personality you sound so tired that you
explained it in a way that sounded more
confusing than it was you're like uh I'm
going to guess we're going to guess the
guest we're going to guess the guest see
we're going to have a look at the list
we're going to pop one up we're g to try
and have a g you know try and gauge who
it might be yeah
and that's what I just said I I'm saying
it more excited you both explained it
like [__] you explain it than Joey
expain better than okay here's how it's
going to work ladies and gentlemen
listen carefully okay we're going to be
shown a 3X3 we don't know who it is and
before we start talking about each
individual one we're going to take a
quick look at it and go hey that seems
like this person's 3x3 we're going to
each have a guess if we're right then
cool if you don't know the guests then
we don't know the guest and we've just
uh shamed all of their family all right
well let's pull one up shall [__] that's
why he's the anime man that is why he's
the anime man all right so give us our
first 3x3 okay okay so what the [__] is
we've got okay it's over here now Okay
so we've got clad or clad after Story is
like Gundam Seed Gundam Seed is that
Gundam Seed I really hope it's not
Gundam Seed we have princess monoke we
have ramama half we have orimo is God
did you make
this we have welcome to the NHK we have
Naruto potentially
we have hajo and we have yuu HW oh this
is tough who the [__] would make this
list can you pull the name okay okay I'm
I'm there is one big like indicator here
even without looking at the guest names
uh are you sorry put
absolutely on the
backg like absolutely 100% this person
grew up in the same era as myself
because there is no [__] way someone
would put Gundam Seed on their list if
it wasn't the very first Gundam and
maybe the only Gundam that they've
watched you know that's if you've seen
any other Gundam you would not put scene
on here that's what I'm saying and no
like nobody else would put it unless
it's like the first Gundam you put on
there yeah wasn't I think Gundam Seed
when it was airing uh on Cartoon Network
or something I don't know where it a uh
it was like the most popular show on on
the entire network in the west I think I
actually might know who this is because
from the list we've been given there is
only one person I know that would have
the have the balls to put seed on here
and also has openly expressed how much
they love Clan ad and
orimo can't no I think it's
diis uh it would make a lot of sense he
does he loves Clan he loves hajim Mana
he loves orimo and he would put he likes
hajo yeah I've never heard him talk
about Haj oo before and I think he's
mentioned Ramah half before yeah I so I
re this is dius I see the degeneracy
like I I know a fellow brother when I
see one and then someone like put Oro
right slap Bank in the center as I would
have done and I think I did do actually
uh see I can already see it right like
didus is like you know he's he's listing
off like the obvious ones that
immediately come to his head like Oro
and like princess monoke HJ you know
Clan stuff like that and his attempt to
seem cultured is him putting welcome to
the N
HK you know what I mean he's like no no
no I actually I it's not all the
mainstream stuff I love I also watch
other ones like welcome to the NHK but
he also forgets welcome to the nhk's
mega horny as well which is also very
dius is this
dius yes yes we know our friends you
like a book he does I don't know anyone
in this day and age who still references
Naruto as much as
him I don't know anyone else who
references he just always says something
Naruto yeah but is that anything like uh
special I don't know I feel like a lot
of people reference Naruto I feel like
Naruto reference is becoming less common
G yeah yeah that's what I'm saying like
it's I'm sure this is how like I don't
know this is probably some older
equivalent involved here true uh I feel
like he he Springs up narrator more than
anyone else or any normal amount any
alled amount should it should be brought
up that is true that is true um one
thing that surprises me being on here
I'm really hoping you have seen more
Gundams or this is I'm just I'm just not
I'm not I'm not I don't think he's seen
more G okay so I don't know what's so
bad about Gundam Seed can you explain to
me why Gundam Seed is bad and what what
even it is well it's a Gundam for one
okay great um it was just I don't know
like have you seen any Gundam
no probably a fair amount of viewers
watching you haven't seen any
Gundams so when most people when most
people bring up what their favorite
Gundams are and I'm talking like the you
know the kind of older the first half of
the Gundam franchise right A lot of
people bring up like Wing a lot of
people bring up double zero is a very
common one
seed like I don't know how do you I'm
trying to figure out the words to
describe why seed is questionable it's
hard uh it's not hard it's just uh the
writing quality [__] jumped off for
Cliff in especially in the second season
um it's that one Gundam that's got mega
mega popular uh I mean you mentioned
wing and uh double O I don't think any
of them hold a candle to how popular
seed got back in the day and it was one
of those Gundams that you look at the
entire history of Gundam right you look
at this entire franchise with how many
shows there are and then it's this one
that gained the Mega mainstream
popularity and it's just confusing
because probably right place right time
maybe it's the sword on line equivalent
you know holy [__] that is actually that
is actually oh my God that is actually
the Perfect Analogy it's the seed is
seed is to the mecca franchise as Sword
Art was to the isaki franchise where it
was just right place at the right time
mega mega popular but not the best
writing at in any stretch of the mean
yeah and you watch gunam seed and that
might be your introduction to gundam and
then you watch any other Gundam and
you're like oh this is [__] yeah yeah
and uh this is like or you watch even
like any other Mecca show and you
realize how uh I don't remember what is
what is Gundam Seed out of 10 on a scale
if you had to give it a rating like a
five for me like 5 six it's pretty
brutal especially after the second
season there's more coffee I need more
coffee do we have do we have a reason
why he does did he say why he chose the
thing things he chose he didn't give any
reasons he didn't give any reasons guess
have given reasons as to
why I do know for a fact that dius
always talks about how much he loves
romance and Slice of Life shows yeah uh
and so I'm assuming that's why clanet
after Story is on here oh he loves like
if you want to if you want to meet
someone who loves clad more than I do
it's daus like daus [__] loves clad
which is based he also loves orima as
well which is not based my I like d is
like a [__] brother to me man every
time I watch a trashy romance show I
know he's like I message him and he's
always into the same [__] you know we
both [__] love Oro he gets the
Masterpiece that his domestic girlfriend
as well he understands that [__] well
well daus just likes car crashes yeah
that's the thing when I when I talk to
daus about shows he often if he one
thing that he always makes very apparent
is that if he feels like he can predict
what's going to happen he's not
interested right yeah and I guess the
reason why he likes Simo and perhaps
maybe domestic
girlfriend is that there's such car
Crashers that he doesn't know where it's
going yeah yeah um that is true to me
that is an indication of a showt that's
good there's an indication of a show
that's just trying to subvert
expectations sure of course if you're
going to [__] your brother that's pretty
that's a good way to submerse I wouldn't
say so okay let let me let me defend the
[__] trashy romance genre okay
because I'm I'm addicted okay see do you
know do you know what I did in the
Christmas holiday I don't know if would
be you know if you know what this is
Joey I watch White Album 2 you watch
White Album 2 yeah first time I [__]
know it say okay my question is you
could have watched anything else because
and you watched White Album to because
uh it was the one [__] Car Crash
romance that I just did not watch what
the [__] is White Album too imagine
school days but without thousands
imagine school days but without the
murdering and it's about that it's I
actually think it's on the same level of
school days in terms of like the pure
[__] shitty reaction and the car
crash of an ending that you got this
like look at this this scream's like mid
2000s trash originally yeah it was
originally an AR I think or or at least
a
visual probably an a from the mid 2000s
uh got mega mega popular in the Doan
world uh and uh and then when the anime
came out I I watched it when it came out
and uh I uh you know i' forgot about it
until you brought it up and I'm really
glad I'm really hoping you didn't bring
it up this was this was an ending where
they set up a they set up like a love
triangle I I [__] love this [__] they
set up a love triangle and then the
author just sets everything on fire and
I [__] love that [__] man that's you
just described a mid 200000 huh sounds
stressful I mean okay maybe maybe it's
because I'm in a you know happy
relationship that this is like I I to to
feel feel something anymore I need this
kind of romance I need this kind of
story in my life man because like my my
real my real life I'm like too solid
your real life you need you need some
[__] SP I need some spice up there
the imagination's going to get to the
point where the only thing that'll like
get his socks rocking is just playing
the most egregious aad out there from
the M 2000s cuz all of them are like
that no but I've I've always liked you
know car crash kind of romances just
because it gives you an emotional
response like you are you know like it's
kind of like drama YouTube you know
except no one's getting hurt it's like
no no one's actually doing something
outrageous it's all in a place of
fantasy and fiction that makes sense but
again over the Christmas holidays you
could have watched literally anything
bro I had a great time man I got [__]
plastered and I watched White Album with
Sydney and we [__] shouted at the
screen for all the characters were doing
and it was a great [__] time this is
the wee equivalent to watching sports
bro no no this is the wee equivalent to
watching 0 fiance I'm being like yo they
did what no she said what yo she slept
with him wait wait this [__] this [__]
came back and th she thinks that she can
take over again ain't no way no it's
it's a great time sounds like horrible
time um one that I am kind of how is
this that you were defending Oro yeah
yeah
so Oro is just that the ending to Oro is
just one of like seeing the reaction to
the internet to the ending of Aro was
one of the most funnest per like
weekends I've had in my life just seeing
the internet melt down that was me with
school days bro that was me with school
days yeah we seeing the ending to school
days and then just Japanese internet
just being like what the [__] did I just
[__] watch see with with school days
I didn't I I guess I was like on forums
and on social media L I was on
tchan tchan caught on Flames that day
what was the reaction like dude everyone
was like wait so was this like an April
fools joke like did this actually is
this the actual like no that they're
setting up for a final final episode
right no it wasn't and people got mad as
[__] but but it was really weird it was
so agree just that half the internet
with a stable mind was like this is the
worst [__] ending have seen and then
the other half of tan was like that was
an absolute Masterpiece I I have a
question about Oro yes I actually don't
know what the [__] Aro is about all I
know is that there's incest that's only
from you I actually I have you never
seen it no cuz it has incest I don't
want to watch that well I mean it's not
the whole way
through just a little bit it's literally
okay let me let me explain to you let me
explain to you she a little bit of inter
a little bit all right let me explain to
you why the internet [__] broke down
in
uh because people don't [__] believe
me when I say this but uh it was a show
that all of us it like pulled like a
reverse UNO card because rmo in season 1
came out and it was a show called uh my
little sister can't be this cute right
and then everyone was meing on it
because haha it's a it's a [__] show
called [__] my little sister can't be
this cute obvious incest bait and then
you actually watch season 1 and people
were like wait they're actually like
acting like real brother and sister like
actual siblings and it turns out to be a
like a pretty interesting look on otaku
and like Akihabara culture in Japan okay
cuz this came out before there was this
huge wave of hey this is like wee
culture uh this is a look into aab 200
when was it 8 9 something like that
something something around that time and
so it was a genuinely interesting and
good show that people hadn't seen before
with what at the time felt like a more
realistic depiction of a brother and
sister in anime and then season 2 came
out and uh that it kind of went it
turned into this kind of Slice of Life
look into otaku culture into more of
like a typical Haram best girl kind of
like show where every girl around him
falls for the main character okay and
got robed bro yeah yeah exactly and then
they released the last three episodes as
an OVA where spoiler he chose his sister
after the first season where everyone's
like no this this ain't an in this ain't
an incest show like kiss or something or
yeah yeah that's only the beginning what
they they they got uh married uh that's
that was the like end of the show uh
they got like fake married um and then
they broke
up because they were brother and sister
because it was illegal yeah and it was
just
seeing the internet [__] go into
flames because of the author just being
like haha this this isn't actually an
incest show just like just joking
actually it was incest the entire time
you guys fell for my reverse baits it it
was just everyone broke down the author
is such a godamn troll because then
because then afterwards he was just like
I'm going have to go in and made
aranga just round two yeah the big
difference between and ARA Sensei aranga
Sensei just didn't even pretend and from
episode one it was just like genuinely
there was a time when I thought Oro for
like season one genuinely I think it's a
good show uh Sensei that was always that
was always in the trash man that was
always to to give orimo the benefit of
the doubt it did as G said have a lot of
interesting aspects to it that was
actually created a compelling story even
for a harm anime yeah but my problem
with it is that it didn't follow through
with that the end and and and the author
was just like no I'm going to make some
D [__] instead what about this do you
think maybe was so compelling to
daus because obviously G this is a big
show favorite of yours what about it do
you think could' be so compelling to be
in the top nine to me Oro was the first
show that I would say turned me into a
weeb I would say before Oro okay here's
here's here's here's what I'm for what
reason God for what reason okay here's
the difference before ormo right I was I
I went through this kind of like
pretentious critic I I have good taste
kind of like you you know everyone goes
to that phase where they're like oh I
went through the Mal top 100 that's my
taste I like Legends of the galactic
heroes I like all of the classics you
just described me in 2033 and then and
then Oro and then I watch Oro and I'm
like huh the first I was I went into
this ready to [__] in it and the first
season I was like wait a minute this is
enjoyable but this goes against
everything that I thought I enjoyed and
I think for I think because at the time
this was a very kind of like original
take on it or a very new take on it I
think that was the first kind of like
show for a lot of people uh in my
generation where it was I think and I
think people still gravitate to it even
now because even though it came out in
2010 there have been so many Oro clones
that have come out since then that have
tried to like replicate that feeling of
the show
to not that much success people just see
right through it in this day and age Oro
doesn't stand out as much anymore
because there's like a million different
shows that revolve around but it does
stand out in a sense because it I would
say out of all of the orimo Clones and
all the shows that kind of bit off orimo
orimo still does Oro best if that makes
sense yeah because there was a point
where it was genuinely I think a good
show yeah and then every every every
show copied the second half of the yo
show uh welcome to the NHK I hear a lot
of people talk very positively about
this one of the shows that's been on my
like I'm sure I'm going to watch this at
some point I never fastic show that is
the anti Oro if Mega depressing yeah it
also deals with otaku culture except the
[__] depressing side of yeah from my
understanding I just seems about like a
show guy a guy struggling with um oh how
to be normal yeah it's kind of Welcome
to the NHK I think is one of the best
anime that uh tackles I didn't want one
welome welcome to the NHK is one of the
best shows in my opinion that tackles
the idea of loneliness in Japan okay uh
because you
know you're talking it's definitely
going to be on camera of God spilling or
something great but um yeah so like yeah
as as G said like you know if if the
ideal weeb world is the main character
of Oro then the total opposite of that
is the main character of w the NHK where
like him being ostra and him feeling
lonely as a result of being an otaku and
struggling to connect to people through
his hobbies and his interests is the
entire philosophy of w to the NHK bit
more of a real take as opposed to oremo
this is this is just sister take this is
just if boj Jack Horseman was a weeb
that is welcome to the NHK that's okay
you saw me okay you
saw it's it kind of yeah it deals with
exactly depressing as Bojack it's
[__] depressing it's pretty
depressing was pretty depress because
it's I mean you know about hiori right
this is the main character is a hiori
and he the entire show is him struggling
to [__] not become a hiori and
actually become a member of society um
sounds like a great show [__] hard he
he just it's brutal like this was before
this came out before kind of like the
whole mental health um awareness was
more of a thing now in this day and age
and it's so with to see this coming out
back in the day before that conversation
was really as prevalent as it is now
it's very poignant even now yeah and it
still hits just as hard um and you know
it's just it's just so funny just
hearing the dichotomy between Oro and
this you're like yeah yeah he [__] his
sister get married yeah it's not a bad
thing and you're like so he's just
trying to be a normal human being like
damn that's tough yeah I I can I can I
can really see like like like it's like
[__] your sister easy pill to swallow
function in a member of society [__]
that's tough dude tough [__] it's like
why why are we at the world where these
two shows are described in this was
really like double dipping into like the
otaku world like at both ends of the
spectrum of like the Wee World with
these two shows uh I am surprised was y
HW show though I've never heard him talk
about yuu HW show uh yeah I've never
heard him talk about either if I knew I
would [__] geek out about you H show
with them but yeah solid Choice
presumably very solid choice
literally shown in and weeb one of the
best 90 shown in shows in my op I think
the most important thing is that he also
has RMA on here as well also good so
he's just you know dipping in all
generations he's got good taste yeah
except for G except for seed I don't
know why for seed what about
Naruto I mean Naruto is just Naruto
isn't it it's prably just Sher number
one that you first followed I imagine
it's like what whichever shown you
follow first for the longest time see I
don't know I'm looking at this and I'm
like was the first anime he ever watched
seed or was a
Naruto I don't think does the first
matter that much it does because it kind
of sets up I I watched Naruto first and
I wouldn't put it at and now you like
Oro so I mean there's a Nostalgia cells
can't for a reason people people tend to
be very even if they it might not be
their favorite they tend to have a
subconscious kind of um kind of tie to
the first real long show they watch
right cuz princess monoa was definitely
his first first anime film guarantee was
my first anime film like a gritty film
it's like a I mean it's one of my
favorite jiggly films yeah it's one of
my favorite as well still haven't
watched it what you never seen I think
you would enjoy it actually you would
really like it it's actually like adult
oh cool yeah it's more adult than
something like Spirited Away uh Spirited
Away is a bit more trippy cuz Spirited
Away is just [__] weird a lot of get
trippy it's pretty trippy yeah it's
pretty trippy trippy as [__] it's
fantastic it's like that's like those
kind of films it's like leaning forward
you have to watch cuz you're like oh
[__] okay let me oh yeah on an okay in
some some scenes it's just like oh [__]
okay they went there yeah uh and then of
course hajim noo considered one of the
best sports anime of all time oh
absolutely it is amazing show one day I
will watch it yeah but it is long it is
long it's just long you have not watched
Haim upo no it's long if I have I've
lied
I I've said that I've watched it lied
you you would love it actually yeah
every every every any single time I see
a clip from the show it looks so goddamn
cool it's seem fun some of the most I
think haimo is some of the most hype you
could get in anime just period like when
I think about the hype anime what comes
up at the top it's something like Gan
Lagan I think is the ceiling of how hype
a a certain show can be Haim was like a
very very close second there for me in
terms of how hype I felt watching a
scene uh or just watching a piece of
fiction I've never had the adrenaline
rush of some of the scenes that have
happened in Hao have you seen you HW uh
I've seen one episode one episode yeah I
think we spoke about this on a on a
podcast uh where I tried watching it and
I I I just I wasn't in the right frame
of mind it also starts off slow as well
it's so slow first episode it's like
okay he died because Togashi didn't know
which direction he wanted to take the
story so it actually started off as like
kind of like a slice of live show until
toachi was like all right I'm I'm going
to pull a Dragon Ball route and just do
an action show yeah yeah all right but
that was daus's list which I think uh
accurately represents everything I know
about him yeah this very so I'm not
going to calling out him out for lying
so that that definitely screamed his
name good job good job daus who is next
all right this episode is sponsored by
vessie listen if you've ever seen a
picture of me or the other boys you know
damn well that we're always wearing
vessis every single time time why let me
tell you why because they're extremely
waterproof they're lightweight Comfort
they're easy on and off and they're
four-way stretched so even fat feet like
mine can get that damn shoe on they got
the everyday classic synthetic exterior
offers a sleek and phys aesthetic making
it suitable for both casual and formal
setting I know Joey wore it to g wedding
it's got a lightweight Soul ensuring
stability and safety and the souls don't
Mark so it's also perfect for indoor
environments I quite often walk 10K in a
day and I wear these shoes all the time
and they are so com comfortable but of
course we can't not mention the storm
burst High rebound dual density midsole
offers extra shielding against Rocky
Roads slush and water but if we get the
full rubber outsole designed with the
raised patent ensuring excellent grip on
all slippery surfaces and of course we
have the waterproof gloves a classic and
new favorite of mine especially in these
cold January days where I need some
loving on my hands and they will Creed
to keep you dry no matter where you day
takes you so Gear Up for your Urban
adventures with vessie go check out
vessie traste for shoes that masterfully
com waterproof protection with Urban
Elegance start your journey with vessie
okay all right here's the next one umu
princess on here I immediately know who
this is you do yeah I I immediately know
who this is no way school days is on
here I immediately know I immediately
know I saw AR Juna I saw school days I
saw made in ays don't tell me um I don't
know actually what's the bottom what's
the bottom right one uh that's the
shinkai of of the dist St STS or
something like that yeah it's the first
shinkai makota short film one of these
is not like the other I know I I know
Pokemon there because the Lugia movies
is [__] movie does slap but not as good
as the not as good as the Mewtwo one
dude come on I mean the first one yeah
yeah the m one goes hard first movie is
definitely the best one is this is this
is this shindo I can't tell no Kev I
think this is Kevin it's Kevin it's
Kevin I look look at this everything
aside from [__] school days has
amazing amazing I just wasn't sure if if
Kevin would put his own his own show on
there K this is Kevin right yeah of
course because literally every show
other than school days is considered to
have some of the best soundtracks in all
of anime yeah it's it's that it's
definitely much it's very much hey this
is composers dude the lukia movie the
soundtrack is [__] insane I don't
remember that it's actually really good
I was this the Japanese version cuz in
the English version I can't even I can't
remember sometimes they would redo songs
in English releases well they did that
for the Digimon movie right didn't redo
there right the sound probably didn't oh
no in in the Digimon movie Digimon movie
The soundtrack's completely different
yeah they um All Stars Allstar is a
track in the Digimon movie they they put
like Bowling For Soup yeah so he's like
Le Les Less Than Jake as
well that's it's actually sick that's
officially in the Digimon movie it the
it is the most late '90s early 2000
soundtrack you'll ever hear I'm I'm I'm
going to say I think they made an
improvement I think it's better I think
the English soundtrack for the digim
movie is better than the original
yeah when that bowling forit track comes
on bro there must be some there must be
some like uh you know you want to used
to watch a movie and you're like trying
to Pirate a movie as a kid and then like
the the Korean version comes and you're
like what the [__] is this I imagine
maybe there's like a a Japanese kid
somewhere try to watch Digimon and then
he pulled up like the English version he
starts hearing all star he's like then
he caught
it Banger holy [__] they had they had
Bare Naked Ladies as well naked
ladies dude that soundtrack is goed it's
such a good soundtrack okay look look
let's let's break this down all right
obviously Kevin's going to put him made
in Abyss cuz he made the [__]
soundtrack for it it could have been a
3X3 of his entire Kevin's Greatest Hits
but it's not so well I think I think
knowing Kev I think Kevin has favorites
he has favorites for sure like maiden
Abyss is probably his his I mean it is
his favorite obviously because it's on
here um Kevin just giv himself the gold
medal okay all right you deserve it
Kevin you know Akira has an amazing
soundtrack mon okay araj Juna also has
an amazing soundtrack um what the [__]
is araj Juna so Aruna was uh it was a
when was it early 90s I think late 80s
something like that uh was it a um was
it a uh what's his name
anaki
show I'm trying to
remember what no no no a
anime 2001 oh wow oh was actually wave
no that was that's the series right uh
yeah yeah it's a series have movie
perhaps is it a movie no I think it's a
series the one oh really yeah it's the
director's cut
yeah is it is it
Anno 2001 what is that ad 200 2001 what
that [__] scroll down scroll down
scroll down for a
second uh no it's
not okay anyway I I have I haven't seen
all of it I've seen clips from it but
it's about well let's let's look at the
M yep cuz I actually don't remember Jun
know adosi is an ordinary Japanese
school girl Conor's like I
sleep
who possesses a childlike curiosity and
a strong admiration towards nature one
day while on a trip with her boyfriend
junah dies from a motorcycle accident
however she's given a chance to live by
an individual named Chris Hawkin well
very English name all sudden he offers
her powers that makes her the Avatar of
time in exchange she must fight to
protect the Earth from evil force okay
so it's like a it's like a early 2000s
uh like
sci-fi but I do know for a fact though
that I have I have when I've talked to
Kevin about like anime music he does
bring up ajuna a lot and he says that
that this series is the reason why he
started making and why he wanted to make
for anime I hope it is cuz it's scored
as 6.78 on my anime so you got have a
good reason for
liking but he but according to Kevin
he's like Aruna has one of the best
soundtracks that he's ever heard in in
all of anime yeah cuz I know I think
what immediately gave this away from me
just immediately seeing this is number
one a lot of of these are films and
films normally have you know a more
especially if you're a composer you know
you're allowed to have I
guess sometimes it's more impactful to
be able to score like music for certain
like for like a feature film whereas for
certain like anime series you know you
kind of just have to make certain tracks
not knowing what final scene they're
going to be used in and that just means
a lot of film scores end up being very
very memorable and very very impactful
um I have talked to him about uh Teran
resonance Zan no Tera as well what an
amazing sound that is his favorite
soundtrack of all time in terms of anime
and it is mine as well it's one of my
favor actually to be fair it does say
something cuz I actually don't remember
much about the show but I do remember
that the songs always very compelling it
was the Icelandic infused music yeah do
like the terrorism though that was fun
too nothing nothing matches terrorism
more than Icelandic music
do you know I don't know if we I don't
know if we need to cut this but you know
you know something uh interesting about
Teran resonance what so okay so the show
is obviously about a group a group of
terrorists right yeah so when this was
airing their I can't remember if it was
their 9th or 11th episode got delayed I
do remember this happening yeah yeah do
you know what dates it addir on 911 yes
oh my
God really yeah holy [__] that was I'm
like when that why it got delayed or it
pushed it back to like I can't remember
I just remember guys hold hold hold on
you know what be really funny we had
such a funny
moment someone in the boardroom was just
like we can make something really we can
send a message with this we can make
something really funny happen right now
but uh no but to me I still think that I
still really really [__] like like Z
no Tera yeah it's a good show was yeah I
remember when it came out everyone was
talking about it and it really I it just
kind of disappeared after that year I
think a lot of people uh were not happy
with the plot and the characters but um
I I don't know something about the
feeling that show gives is there's been
very very few shows and a lot of this is
to do with the soundtrack but a lot of
this just a lot of individual scenes as
well I don't fully remember what the
plot was but I know that they were
terrorists and they had a a solid
reason hope so that's it that's all I
remember but I I also remember being
like ah okay we we did terrorism and uh
and now it's over and now the show's
over it's like okay cool terrorism is
over guys it's like uh I I I remember
watching it feel like it should have
been longer it was what 12 episodes
right yeah it was 12 episodes cuz you
know nowadays we're starting to get some
24s popping up and even longer that was
I think when this came out it was there
was only only 12 episode anime is coming
out does Kevin have any reasons for why
he put these on or no no reason I mean I
I mean I guess it's self I can pretty
much guess which with most I just want
to know why he put school days on there
cuz I'd love to shake his
hand just because uh let's just say kin
didn't put it Kevin didn't put it on
there for the [__] soundtrack he was
probably grinning going like I could do
a cheeky move here put school days on my
Leist that's my Cav is that
your like a breaking Geer go in I just
wake up school days watch Kevin Kevin
you realize now that you are one of the
most actual respected you know staff
members in the anime industry right now
especially in composers you know fan and
Industry alike what the [__] is school
days put like doing on here Kevin what
is it doing on here I mean my respect
went not
for you know well deserved I would say I
don't want to hear if I didn't already
love you I love you even more now I
don't want to be listening to [__] M
and Abyss having the existential crisis
of my life and he definitely did this
for me and then in the back of my mind
I'm like you know school days played a
part in Mak you know you're talking like
you're talking like anime creators with
the most well adjusted views on most
thing go God come
on I mean what I am also surprised about
is him putting uh voice of the distance
star yeah the [__] cuz like what is this
thing so this was this is shinkai
Makoto's first directorial debut it was
a what like a it was a short film I
think it was like 20 30 minutes or
something uh kind of Mecca but also
including a lot of like the shinkai isms
of like you know lots of emotional
scenes and stuff like that it does have
a good soundtrack to be fair does it I
don't I don't remember I I remember I
remember the soundtrack being pretty
good but the problem is is that I barely
remember the plot because cuz it was
[__] cuz it was not very good cuz Mako
Shinko didn't learn how to do plots
until your name uh is he the director
who keeps making the same movie or is it
okay weaing with you 5 cm second okay I
mean that's a very generalization I said
but that's generally makes it generally
makes very similar things yeah no cuz I
remember you're not going to believe it
his next film is a romance
okay I could have figured that one out
well it's he does like different
variations but I remember before your
name different variations it's almost
more insulting I think you're saying
yeah just the he does the same thing he
changes it up sometimes his I actually
watched his newest film over Christmas
and it was like oh the the the SC yeah
um that was kind of felt like shink Kai
was like I'm going to try making a gibli
film that's that's what it felt like and
then there was romance in there and that
that was the part that actually was the
weirdest part because before he did meai
which was another one that no no that's
uh that's uh the other
director before that he did what's the
other rad Wims [__] thing weathering
with you weathering with you yeah I
liked weathering with you yeah a lot of
people like that I I prefer to have your
name I hav I did not yeah but you're
[__] you have a bon for your name so
I just think that he like here's the
thing um about shinkai because I am a
big fan of shinkai and I'm very familiar
with I've watched everything that he's
put out um something that was always
strong in his Works pre your name was
that he always had a he always I could
always tell the idea and the emotions
and the feeling that he wanted to put
across in his films like that was always
something that really resonated with me
no matter what shinkai did including
voice of a distant Star as well um and
the thing that I always thought he was
missing was he would always have this
idea or emotion that would resonate with
me but the plot would always be [__]
boring you know it would always yeah in
my in my opinion in my opinion it was
more like you know cuz my favorite
shinkai film was 5 ctim per second but
not because I think it has like a really
good plot it's more so the fact that
like sh as you said like shinkai's
movies a lot of the times were not like
a singular story that was being told it
was kind of just like a collection of
emotions just like kind of stitched
together yeah I mean you 5 cm per second
I think it's a beautiful idea for a
story but there's no story but what's
the story there's no story what what is
the compelling like plot line of that
you know and why is it called 5 cm per
second cuz that's how fast it felt the
story was going no it's called 5 cm/
second because that's the speed which a
cherry pedal
Falls that's legitimately why it's
called 5 cm second cuz the the the
cherry blossom falling Motif is just a
lot in that movie yeah but I I feel like
he discovered like he he discovered
something with your name where he took
all of these some of these ideas and
emotions and he weaved it into what I
thought was a pretty compelling plotline
and I thought that was the only piece of
the puzzle he was missing sure and then
he found out with your name and then he
was like I don't know how to do
something else other than than some kind
of like the same kind of ideas as that
um so like one thing I respect about Suz
is that he tried something new it's it's
definitely different from weathering
with you that's good
um I would have liked more if it
actually did not have any romance in it
funnily enough you asking shinkai to not
do yeah yeah I I thought that was the
least interesting part of that plot uh
it's like asking light no auths to not
do incest not going to happen well well
funnily enough I always have thought the
romance part you guys have seen your
name right right yeah I thought I also
thought no you never seen your name
no I I I've had I've had this struggle
honestly with watching uh anything
romance related in anime um and I I
don't have the problem with normal uh
like Western media I I I just find I
don't know what it is about Japanese
Japanese interpretation Japanese
interpretation of romance stories that I
just don't connect with really a lot of
them I just don't care about I'm
completely the opposite I I see I see a
western romance story and I'm like you
know it's just like except the notebook
notebook is
Banger it is it's my favorite
unironically it is my favorite Western
romance
film like all these women [__] cry
about like oh Titanic is the most
[__] blah blah I'm like no it's just
a [__] chip syn kind of that kind of
romance I don't really [__] care
about much either that's that's like
very that's very like angelical
Christian interpretation of romance I
don't know if this is a hot take but the
notebook gave me the feeling of a
Japanese interpreted
Romance
I'm in the sense that it's like if if
the notebook ever got an anime
adaptation I could totally see Shen Kai
doing it because it gives that I it
gives that same feeling of like the
notebook having this like it has you
know unlike a lot of shinkai films it
does have this coherent story but
there's so many different emotional
points that feel very shinkai in the way
that like how the characters change and
develop and stuff like that I mean like
for one it's just a really solidly
written story in my opinion um I think
the only reason why it's had this stigma
is because it's the [__] relationship
tester movie that everyone talks about
right but when I actually finally sat
down and watch it with Aki I was like
wow that was actually a [__]
beautiful movie I I cried in the
notebook bro like I think I I watched
the notebook too it it was a great film
um I too watched it and it was I don't
remember much about it it was Japanese
so I didn't feel anything you know CH
was good in it so Channing Tatum was
good in it CH Tatum isn't it Channing
Tatum it's not Channing Tatum wa who is
it in the not Ryan goling it's uh wa was
there another movie around that time
with with ch Tatum that I wait it was
Ryan goling wasn't it was it Ryan goling
was it Ryan goling I I I just I just
kind of like it's that guy I just kind
of like what's the guy yeah it's Ryan go
[__] there must been I got cuz I
remember I was dating this girl and she
forced me to watch like three of these
films and I they all blended into one my
Tatum in it at that time I swear Jump
Street no no I swear there's a movie cuz
before 21 before Chan was a comedy actor
he was doing romance only was he do you
remember this no I remember this yeah
channy Tatum was the romance I think I
found out about channy Tatum through 21
jum stre that that that was when he
started to like are you serious that was
when he started to like pivot but before
wanted to like the American like romance
goto heart really wow I did not know
that um that's why he did a bunch of
weird films to try and kind of get out
of that notion umz what what American
what Wesson romance stor you like and I
when I said this out loud and I know
that we talking about it I was trying to
think in my head cuz I knew you're going
to ask me this and I'm trying to think
of a piece of media that I think I did
romance really well oh um what's the
[__] Jim Carrey one uh Eternal
Spotless Mind Eternal M that's a romance
technically I I love and and I I swear I
feel like I I haven't seen this ever in
a in a and maybe that you can correct me
cuz I I'd love to be wrong about this uh
there's rarely ever stories about
romance going horribly wrong that's why
I like my [__] romances man no yours
doesn't go horribly wrong I think I
think what is talking about is that it
seems like it's going in the right
direction and then it ends up going
horribly wrong because the protagon so
does in life what are you talking about
your is what are you talking I stuck my
dick in my little sister your one is
your your your one your one goes wrong
from minute one no no it doesn't go
wrong from okay this is this is this is
a horrible example right but I really
[__] love how they deal with romance
and Peep
Show where this are you [__] serious
where this [__] mess of a a comp cuz
cuz romance is super messy in real life
that's one that's one step away from the
[__] Dennis system man that's so
that's so [__] up but there's I I love
the whole Arc with like Mark getting
married in because in this Peep Show he
gets married to this woman that he
doesn't really know if he wants to get
married to but he just thinks it's the
right thing to do
that they a
story W media we have ACH of these
stories about stuff like that I feel
like in anime there would never be a
show like that there would never be a
show where a guy gets married turns out
he doesn't like his wife and it but and
and they would commit to it in a way
that would actually make you think hold
on these guys are horrible people uh it
would make you think like oh his wife is
a a Demon Lord that's why he doesn't
like her it's like nothing we they can
never make an like just unlikable
character
that we can figure out that we don't
like it's like hey this is a character
you shouldn't like I think it's because
it just hits too close to home for L of
Japanese people that's what I want but
Japanese don't want that how many how
many Japanese people right are in
[__] Loveless marriages why can't we
get a [__] anime about a Loveless
marriage that's why shows like aetco was
so not popular in Japan because it's too
close to home in Japanese people don't
want to watch anim that crazy that it
was about [__]
animals like w this is too real but they
were still but they were still like yo
Haida is totally me dog this guy said he
doesn't like work I don't okay no no I'm
based on what you say on I'm going to
say something [__] outrageous okay
all right [__] you want escapism no
[__] rent a girlfriend man that is
almost exactly without the marriage part
but with the everyone being [__]
yeah but here's where you're going to
lose him they're all high schools well
okay no University students actually
well they're all University students but
it's the suspension of disbelief is to a
degree where I'm like ah I think this is
just this is silly but I think if there
was it was grounded in some some reality
like how come every single goddamn love
triangle in an anime has to be so corny
and stupid why can't it be an actual
love triangle like you mean where they
have to actually like how the they would
have to actually explore the mechanics
of what it would actually mean to have
to juggle this realistic love triangle
and how [__] up it would be why that's
why golden time is one of my favorite
romances cuz I did exactly that in my
opinion that's probably the most
realistic depiction of of a love
triangle um they also did that in Ichigo
100% I think the problem is that also a
lot of the times if if you were to
really depict an actual love triangle
you probably wouldn't like the
protagonist much MH yeah uh and then you
end up with school days yeah so how do
you how do you juggle that but I feel
like that could be like and why golden
time is so compelling mhm because it it
tries to do something different and
doesn't play the safe route of in the
romance here here's what's going to
happen here's are the two people going
to get together it's all going to be
very happy oh maybe you know and and my
my pet peeve is that they're like this
romance is tough or how do we how do we
throw some spice into this romance and
make it it kind of difficult I don't
know [__] kill that kid or kill
someone else around them that makes them
have to be sad as opposed to having some
actual problem stem from their romance
like let's make the problem come from an
out like an outward Source not not
something that they're having to deal
with and I feel like that's a much more
mature way of approaching romance that
we are a little more inclined to
exploring in a western way but that's I
I don't think we do as like a good job
either uh but I feel like we just do not
get this flat out at all in anime and
that's kind of the reason why I'm not
too huge into anime romance anime yeah I
think just in general everything you
describe I don't want everything to
depressing by the way I'm just saying I
would like mature I actually uh give me
give me more depressing romance stories
think I think the reason for it works
for me in anime is because there is that
suspension of disbelief uh because I
think I have a of the same problems that
you have with romance except when I see
real actors I'm like this isn't this
ain't real this this is like some no no
when when I see real actors uh that
brings it out uh brings me out of the
story even more because because with
anime it's like a animated medium
something in my brain just just thinks
okay you have a higher suspension of
disbelief just because you know that
this is kind of like a fantasy cartoon
world but when I see real actors and
something doesn't
replicates real life how I know it that
actually makes the intricacies of what
doesn't work that's crazy I come out
even more for me I feel the opposite cuz
I feel like when I'm watching a movie
and there's some really talented actors
uh and just seeing all the little body
language that they're doing to really
sell this emotion or what they're
thinking uh I think that's just say we
just you cannot replicate in anime
because you can't have all these CH
little body movements they all have to
be deliberate whereas an actor can kind
of put in these maybe an arm movement
maybe a tongue in the like literally
like I don't know you know like little
really tiny little body movements that
we just can't express in anime that can
really sell an emotion or a scene or
doubt well I I would go the opposite way
where you know animation is a different
form where you can express a certain
idea or a certain Motion in a different
way than any real actor can you know you
can draw Expressions you can exaggerate
movement and emotions without making it
feel like it's out of place just because
it takes place in a world of cartoons so
it's I think I think it totally for me
it's I'm kind of in between you guys
where for me it just totally depends on
the actual story that is taking place I
think some stories works better in
animation abolutely some stories work
better in live action and I don't really
have a preference that's why I generally
prefer liveaction stuff for romance just
because I find that those very slight
body movements really sell romance you
know the the little things I had that
feeling when I watched the anime version
of I want to eat your pancreas and then
I watched the liveaction version of it I
way prefer the live action version of it
because of what you said where you can
add a lot more to it yeah there there's
like the feeling of the emotion was just
so much more potent with real people as
oppos to the anime but there are some
stories that I would absolutely want
more in anime than oh totally um just
how it goes um interesting yeah um um
other than that though I mean Ghost in
the Shell Akira amazing soundtracks
totally get it uh the Lugia movie I
guess that's just Nostalgia for Kev um
he a Pokemon it was ente was the third
one right uh was the third was the third
was pretty good but I remember not being
as solid as the other two but I know a
lot of people love the ente movie yeah
and the celby movie as well that one was
and there's the unknown movie The
Unknown movie wasn't there a movie about
the unknowns Pokemon am I crazy I don't
know I haven't seen all of is there a
movie I SAR there's a movie about the
unknowns and then [__] I think the
last Lucario got his own
movie movie I think the last one I
actually remember watching was oh maybe
it was oh yeah it might have been the
third one actually third one the unknown
cuz I think the unknowns played a huge
part in that movie the last one I
watched was the celby movie that was a
good movie too that was great and then
there was uh was there a Latios and
Latias one yeah [__] me bro they printed
money Bren and money amen good well
solid list Kevin solid list from Kevin
uh definitely this is your composer's
favorite anime kind of list uh is that
Ghost in the Shell the movie it is yeah
it is the movie I haven't watch movie
only the series it's good it's not
doesn't matter everything about ghost in
the showell no matter what except for
maybe the live action movie Everything
slaps pretty hard oh yeah what about the
2045 the new one oh I don't we don't
talk yeah we don't talk okay I forgot
about that one the back flipping up the
stairs still my favorite if it's a ghost
n shell like anime anime yeah like an
actual anime still my favorite scene
ever when the guy gets all his money
from getting the one yen from Bank
transaction still my favorite scene ever
yeah so good all right good job Kevin
good job all right this episode is
sponsored by Better Health around New
Year we always get obsessed with how to
change ourselves instead of just
expanding on what we're already doing
right and maybe you finally organized
one part of your space and you want to
tackle another or maybe you're just
taking your supplements every morning
and now you want to actually eat
breakfast too therapy helps you find
your strength so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick boys if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge I mean
honestly I think more guys especially
guys in our age group and position uh we
could benefit a lot by just being able
to talk to someone because in my own
personal experience not a lot of guys or
not enough guys talk about themselves
and what we're feeling enough age
sometimes is out of embarrassment
sometimes you just don't have the right
friends to open up to um which is why
you know in my personal experience I
started off with some talk therapy that
didn't necessarily mean anything was
wrong or I needed to fix anything about
myself I think therapy has a bad kind of
like image of that but it did help me a
lot to understand myself so celebrate
the progress you've already made visit
betterhelp.com trash to get 10% off your
first month that's betterhelp
hp.com trash thank you the better help
for sponsoring this episode back to the
episode okay so we have our next 3x3 up
and I can already tell who this is wait
really I I I'm I'm pretty confident I'm
pretty damn confident so we got Hunter
Hunter 2011 I assume yo Dragon Ball Z
code gas attack on time Jus kaen Death
Note Vinland Saga what's that last one
code gas oh it's code why do they pick
that pict no K is up there so what's
that one that is what is that what's the
last one that is
code it's not that looks like the that
looks like the zero mask I don't know
what that is oh cash ear
sins cash ear oh my God I know that
what's cash huh the [__] is Cash ear
cashion sins is the beta
Cod I would I wouldn't go that far um is
this Charlie's I'm pretty confident it's
Charlie got this is the most male anime
fan generic list ever okay yeah that
makes
sense that made sense not a single
romance or or slice of
to be seen not a single Sports Anime
everything is action manly stuff
[__] men men boys boys boys this is the
boys is this Charlie yeah got what's the
bottom right one oh it is cash and wow
he watched cash and sins what the [__]
is cash and sins I don't even know what
this is it did it come out before or
after I can't remember it's before right
it is an action anime that's all I
really know about it I I didn't watch it
I didn't actually watch I haven't
watched it in years
um uh I think it might be kind of like
it's a mecha I'm pretty sure 7.5 on Ma
that is literally the most seven like
that means it's like a five out of 10
but one thing that I I am guessing why
Charlie put this on is that it just has
a very badass art style and a very
badass visual kind of like identity that
is true uh which you know I know Charlie
would be a big fan of does Charlie have
a reason for putting cash and SS in
no all right well I mean okay let's
let's go let's go through this even
though this screams this already screams
yes makes sense because he said on trash
taste that that's his favorite anime of
all time uh it's valid which is valid I
could see why someone would be their
favorite I know you went through a phase
of collecting Yu-Gi-Oh cards as well so
yuio is just great I just love the memes
I just love the I don't know the yuoh
phandom seems like they have a good time
it's so quotable as well it's such a
great show you're the dub is great
you're what you're a third rate jewelist
no you're a fourth rate jewelist with a
third rate deck or something see the
problem with the dub is that I don't
know like I literally can't tell which
scenes are from the original dub and
which scenes are from Yu-Gi-Oh bridge I
think I think that one I quot from the
bridge actually so I think the No it
should have been me I think that's from
the I think that's from the that's from
is it should have been me not him that's
from the original don't [__] know
anymore quoting like well the a bridge
my deck has no pathetic cards yui which
I think is from Yu-Gi-Oh a bridge if I
and then obviously the [__] pot of
greed meme is from the the [__] brid
that's from which one pot of greed
they're like what does pot of greed do
and like no one ever no one knows no one
knows what po of greed does I know I I
think that just became a meme because
every time po of greed came on G came on
they would always explain the power even
though it was the most simple card you
could possibly pull from the deck and
wasn't it like it was like that you
explain how pot of greed works by using
pot of greed or something yeah and then
I and then I summon another partt of
greed I I unfortunately have no idea
which memes yeah like you said come from
the ab brid and which come from the
actual dub I have have you noticed pot
of greed is basically just every ugly
bastard [__] design you've seen from
H yeah it is kind of confusing and kind
of concerning yeah look look at this
[__] man it's my favorite [__] card
bro can we agree that the it's that
smile you saw and got turned on and
thought hold on now wait a minute wait a
minute oh have an actual pot of green
that's actually kind ofad that's really
really sick I I I think the Dual disc is
probably the dra CS right the hardest
piece of equipment in of all time it
goes so hard the what dual dis oh
[__] coolest piece of anime
merchandise you canid every K so iconic
having one I I had one as a kid you did
I couldn't I couldn't get my parents to
buy me one I wanted one of these so bad
when I was a kid holy f it was so sick
but I remember it was so annoying having
to keep your arm like up all the time
while you're playing but it it felt so
[__] badass that you didn't even mind
I what a cool piece of equipment that is
the coolest card game kind of like piece
of equipment that has ever come out
that's crazy that someone's making a
video being like I got a real dual D
like it's some kind of ancient artifact
where I just had one as a kid and I'm
like [__] what I loved was the little
section uh above where you yeah where
you could like put your actual deck
inside of it and you can pull it out
yeah and there's the graveyard was at
the bottom and your life points were
there it was such a cool such a [__]
cool piece of [__] genius God I wish
that yu- came out when nerd culture was
a bit more um accepted because yeah Gees
unironically one of the coolest things
ever I would love to see what a high
like high spec build
an actual an actual High speec custom
build of a jewal disc would look like
cuz obviously this looks like you know
want to play yu- with it sure I really
want to I've never played yuoh before
you want I've never played y before I
I've played Yu-Gi-Oh a few times in my
in my life but I've recently played the
forbidden Memories PS1 game oh yeah yeah
uh which came out before the official
rules of Yu-Gi-Oh were established and
uh I played it cuz there's a this they
it's like the craziest speedrun of all
time oh yeah yeah the game is [__]
it's RNG yeah they made the game
impossible it's so [__] hard um isn't
like the the 100% record is like 70
something hours or something yeah
because you have to get like 700 cards
and some of the cards actually a lot of
the cards have 0.1 drop rates so you
have to just grind and it's like K
Konami was just hated kids well that was
a fun game and may it made me really
want to play more Yu-Gi I I love it's so
cool the monster designs are just so
cool so cool yeah I mean of course
Attack on Titan is on there as well uh I
saw his video where he did very much
enjoy the ending uh on the same I I mean
I think Charlie puts it on the same
level as code gas now just as a whole DN
as his like favorite anime uh DBZ he
obviously grow up with I assume yes same
with like uh death note I would assume
Finland Saga yeah I mean who [__]
doesn't like like Hunter Hunter V Saga
like who doesn't like it uh J Kon I'm
not surprised not surprised I think it's
if you're watching dud of kaon right now
well I guess SE well when this is when
this is out it's finished airing but
there's like two week two episodes left
before it's so hard not to think that
it's like [__] amazing I just all
like it's the only anime I really want
to keep watching every week it's like
the latest Shia Arc has just been that
modern shown in Arc classic in my
opinion it's insane people are going to
be talking about this Arc for
generations to come so that doesn't
surprise me but yeah it's this is this
is it this is the boys only Club you
know this is sometimes might I don't
know if your guys's Twitter feed has
been just taken over by Shonen fans
recently I think it's because J K
thankfully not is it not no every day I
log on to my Twitter and someone is
making a certain thread of like oh here
are some manga panels that go hard oh
I've seen those yeah yeah manga panels
that go hard on and [__] like that and
it's the same [__] 10 shows it's it's
like throwing D every now well there was
this like out of nowhere incest scene in
Jutsu kaison recently and that kind of
blew up and I I remember when I watched
it I was like
huh they kept that in they kept that in
yeah there was just a random incest part
that kind of came out of nowhere yeah it
was really weird it literally came out
of nowhere God safe yeah and and and it
it was really funny watching Twitter
react cuz they were like it was like a
bunch of like all the cuz there was this
one tweet that blew up that was like
ain't no way they put this in the anime
and it was just showing off in not but
but even more concerning incest with
like a really older sister and a very
young brother oh switching they're
actually and they're actually blood
related they're blood related it's none
of this like step sibling [__] they
fully committing and it was just out of
nowhere in the middle of like the most
hyped [__] ever and they were like
incest you like [__] what Jesus
Christ and then all the replies were
like Vegeta with like bloodshot eyes
like screaming being like why is she so
bad
though and it's like what is wrong with
Twitter it was like literally like
Vegeta coughing up blood being like I
don't care though I
would it's like what is wrong with
Twitter like what have we what have we
done what have we done to these people
it's it's so amazing how like DBZ is
just one of those shows where every non
DBZ anime fan just loves to clown on
that Community but [__] me they make
they still make some of the best goddamn
memes and reaction images honestly after
modern showen I'm like maybe maybe we
were too maybe we were too harsh on DBZ
fans well I think it's cuz Goku and
Vegeta have such Rec like they're so
recognizable which lends to their mem
ability in the same way that like Mario
and Sonic are often Meed because they're
so widely recognized yeah tot I'm just
I'm just liking the fact that there are
more anime screenshots that are just
becoming widespread memes now like I the
one I've seen recently that's been
spread around is the one where like
gon's about to go for the attack and
just like got his on shoulder which is
like normally used when someone's like
overshooting a tweet or someone's like
someone's like saying something that
might have been going a little bit too
far and someone just replies that and
I'm like like that's so [__]
good oh my God yeah um I mean there's
not much else to say about this one good
taste Charlie I mean Charlie this is
just good taste we know this is good
taste like your your bro comes to you
who is like hey I want to get into anime
welcome to the starter pack
yeah all right all right let's look at
the next one moving on oh [__] okay ooh
wow all right so we have Teran resonance
uh Afro
Samurai uh helling Death Note One outs
what's the left one that looks familiar
there's there's one thing that stands
out to me
yeah thumb tennis [__] coku and we got
hand shakers in the bottom right which
is one of the
it's one of the worst shows ever made
all four is that hand shakers or is that
whz I can't it's hand shakers this has
to be shindo L right you reckon I don't
know if it is I really you know I love
shindo and I really hope he doesn't say
hand oh wait no M I think it might be
mood you know why cuz Mudan told me he
loved hand shakers one time what yeah
and I was like wait isn't that like the
worst anime of the year when it came out
like yeah so this is definitely mood I
[__] with one outs though 1 is 1 is
great sick sick is this is this Mudan oh
my God mudon why the [__] would you put
hand shakers on there I I saw hand
shakers and I was like I it's either
shindell or Mudan and I'm leaning more
towards Mudan just because um from a
visual standpoint like from a purely
visual standpoint it's pretty impressive
how shout out to go hands yeah it's it's
pretty impressive how bad something can
be on a from a a visual standpoint it's
it's not like it's it's not like it's
bad um and nobody cuz nobody's trying
someone is trying the team is trying
really hard to make something look
visually interesting yeah the team said
how many
text yes didn't it look [__] they just
added way too many different textures so
it just looks horrendous they they added
way too many textures and I think at
that point they discovered like uh
Dynamic camera movement and they tried
using that [__] for everything it's it's
like the equivalent
you know when you're making your first
PowerPoint presentation and you learn
about the star WIP transition and you
use that for every single slide that's
what that's what it felt like the it's
like you do that with every single slide
and all the text is in word art that's
that's that's what it's like rainbow
font word art yeah so so what are the
what's the the three in the bottom left
corner what are those three the one with
the or oh the the orb one yeah what's
that one hamater that is hamaty and that
is a [__] great
series and then Prince of Tennis Prince
of
Tennis I don't know much about koku um I
would be very very interesting all I
know is that the opening is one of my
favorite openings from that uh from that
year in fact it's an absolute Banger
opening watched the first four episodes
and I don't remember anything about it
all what was that show
about some it was time travel thing was
it time travel I'm not sure I don't even
remember I also maybe watched the the
first two or three episodes and
thennis that's surprising That's a
classic I thought that was I haven't met
anyone who said that's their favorite
sports anime you'd be surprised a lot of
people in ja I know in Japan it's
popular yeah it's huge but in the
western it's one of my I would say like
guilty pleasure Sports Anime because the
the one thing that Prince of Tennis and
a lot of Sports Anime does that I
personally don't really like is the
whole like [__] power up thing I
[__] love that in sports but the but
shows like to tennis do it in a way
where it's just [__] didn't he hit
like the like hit like the sun or
something or no he okay okay so let me
let me explain one do you start with let
me let me explain the play by play cuz I
know exactly the one you're talking
about I might have talked about this
before but there is a scene where one of
the powers is Tesa tesone he has a power
called tesas zone right and uh the power
the power is no matter where you want
the ball to go when you return it to him
the ball will always spin towards his
Zone of control right so that's so
that's the power so the visual metaphor
that they go that they go to huh orbit
is that so Tesa is like kind of like the
beginning of everything the start of the
universe basically this is okay uh every
time you hit a ball it always orbits
around him and then the balls turn into
planets that turn into the Galaxy that
turn into the universe and Tess started
the big bang and the Big Bang turns into
a tennis ball oh I think and then he
hits the tennis ball and then the ball
turns into an asteroid that wipes out
the
dinosaurs oh that's SI so so good it's
like seph's final attack it's so good
but like that's the thing it's like prin
Prince of Tennis and uh and Ice shield
21 are the two sports shows in my
opinion where these like completely
unrealistic [__] power offs just
make for some of the most entertain
like's [__] Powers too I I thought
kroo was just kind of whatever I like
them I like them yeah I like them I wish
I wish KOCO went further like Prince and
Tennis did I actually the when it was
when Prince of Tennis started going a
little bit further that it started to
lose me really um yeah I think Tes Zone
was like funny um I mean I wasn't taking
that scene seriously at all I didn't
take the entire show seriously though
there was a point where I took it
seriously um and then I kind of realized
number one uh I think I [__] despised
the main
character is he a dick or like why okay
like I just I I was I was with him until
it kind of made me realize that he's
like this like 11 12y old Prodigy who's
just so [__] cocky and uh arrogant
and I'm like man imagine if he existed
in real life and could you imagine 11
12y old going mother mother yeah exactly
that's what I was saying he points his
[__] Dennis racket at you and uh you
do and go
I'm like you are 12 and I'm like you
listen to you little
[__] shut
up yeah um but like Prince of uh Prince
of Tennis was actually my first Sports
Anime as well I I still have a lot of
nostalgia over it but I can't it was fun
it was stupid fun I can't say it's
better than other sports anime that I've
watched after Prince of Tennis that's
why I say it's kind of like my guilty
pleasure Sports show cuz it's like a
sports show that's so ridiculous that
you can't take it seriously and it just
goes beyond the Sports Anime I love that
we have death note and then Sports Death
Note on here yeah one outs I love one
outs so one is such an underrated sport
anime it's it's not many people talk
about it anymore but this is my kind of
like pick for a Sports Anime that not
not enough people have watched so good
and I still think the quality is there
if you want to watch Death Note but uh
with the Death Note logic applied to
baseball watch one outs does Mudan have
uh opinions no you didn't get any okay
cuz like Afro Samurai is an interesting
pick I mean it's a [__] fantastic
show but I've never heard him even
mentioning Afro Samurai I mean the fact
that Samuel Jackson voices oh yeah uh he
produce crazy I'm not sure actually he
was I think he was like one of the lead
staff in that I think he either wrote it
or produced it or something I actually
never watched it I just know that Samu
Jackson voices him oh you would love it
really you would love it it's such a
good show uh helling is like I mean yeah
who doesn't like Hing I love the D of
helling English is so [__] good it's
just it's just [__] handshake is like
why I I can see why he likes it really I
mean it's I can't see why anyone would
like it mid loves bad things yeah he
loves I get that cuz he loves he he
loves weird [__] no I get that but like
you know there's I have a lot of shows
that I love where it's like it's so bad
that it's good but hand shakers wasn't
even it's so so bad that it's good it's
just so bad on a visual perspective
even a storytelling perspective well
storytelling perspective I think was
just I can't power up unless I'm
touching a girl's hand that's literally
the entire premise of handshake story
telling perspective was very generic you
know but from a visual perspective it is
it is actually like incredible I'd like
to imagine that he's rebuttal all that
we're saying in the in the yeah the text
notes right here this why wrong would
say something like he'd look at you dead
in the face and go yeah and it's awesome
they hold hands that's what he would say
that was a really good
mood
yeah I do like how out of everything
here there's just this nice F good anime
that's H matery you know I never
actually watched it what if there's if
there's one H shakers isn't the thing
that uh stands out to me the most in
this one uh because it's actually H maty
cuz it proves to me that Mudan isn't a
robot he's a yeah he's a human with the
Motions cuz everything else I'm like ah
okay this is like only an AI could enjoy
hand shakers you know I can I can
understand the enjoyment uh from from
just a purely fascinating from from a
purely technical perspective that is
[__] fascinating H matery is just so
[__] feel good um it looks feel good
it's yeah it's it's would you recommend
I would actually recommend I I only the
only thing the only reason I think that
more people didn't talk about it was
because it came out in a year that was
an absolute Banger of anime years in in
terms of shows coming out so it just got
swept under the rug um but it's one of
those shows that does this whole you
know showing the relationship between a
father and a daughter really really well
if you watch H matsi you will and you
are a father uh and you have a daughter
this is this is the show for you cuz uh
it'll make so it's aagi drop with a good
ending it's not it's not even good yeah
yeah yeah yeah kind of yeah all right
all right you sold me all right all
right cool thanks moving on let's do the
next I'm looking forward to the amount
of [__] he's going to talk SE a lot of
death notes on the list so far and teror
resonance as well I think that's the
second is that third time we've seen
Death Note now or yes I think so selling
a little or a lot Shopify helps you do
your thing however yet Ching my fellow
business enjoyers Shopify is a global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of business let us do
business together yes from the launcher
online shop stage to the first real life
store stage all the way to the did we
just hit a million orders stage Shopify
is there to help you grow whether you're
selling scented soap offering outdoor
outfits Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform their inperson POS
system wherever and whatever you're
selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout 36% better on
average compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less effort thanks to Shopify magic your
AI powered Allstar the thing I really
like about Shopify is that no matter how
big or small your business is they have
something to help everyone along the way
and they give you everything you need to
take control of your business Shopify
power is 10% of all e-commerce in the US
and Shopify is the global force behind
all birds Ries in Brooklyn and millions
of other entrepreneurs of every size
across 175 countries so what are you
waiting for sign up for a $1 per month
trial period at shopify.com sltr all
lowercase go to shopify.com trash now to
grow your business no matter what stage
you're in that's shopify.com sltr see
you soon fellow entrepreneurs all right
say no more say no
more yep yep 32 one Emily
y I saw Fruits Basket I saw [__] card
capter I saw oron I saw [__] what else
is there everything is that Tokyo Mumu
in the bottom there that is Tokyo mimu
on the bottom yes I mean yeah every show
is um follows girls this is everything
Emily
draws this literally everything Emily
draws so there's n uh fruits basket K
Saka or k panning stocking which is
based um [__] kba Tokyo Mumu and
what's the right one there uh ski and
loafer that's that's something they add
this year yeah they love Skip and lo
Skip and loafer is great uh I didn't
see yeah genuinely I know why Emily put
Skip and loer there that show screamed
Emily it looks like it looks like Emily
Drew that doesn't it it's cute it's
Feelgood it's one of my favorite
romances that aired this year as well
and it's been a long time since I've
seen characters that actually feel like
people and not anime characters um it's
just a very genuine show honestly the
one that sticks out to me is panion
stocking I did not expect I mean I I
assume Emily's going to say like oh I
like panty stocking because the art
style is so unique which it was and it
still is to this day but it just I don't
know does it didn't it doesn't seem like
a show that Emily would be into you know
what I mean I can I'm I'm like hang out
with Emily I wouldn't be surprised if
she put this on here uh because she saw
it was like you know knowing what type
of person Emily is and the background
that she has though it's like seeing
panty in the stocking for the first time
and just hearing the amount of [__]
swearing yeah just how grossly uh just
how gross it is at some point she's like
oh oh my God maybe this is like
Awakening something in me I don't I
don't know why why do I why do I kind of
like why do I kind of dig this what the
hell I feel like saying [__]
they they just say [__] and [__] in my
anime and it has a transformation
sequence as well like magical girls what
yeah because pan stalking is just a
magical magical girl Series in disguise
right it's so good yeah and P soing
season 2 coming out soon [__] yeah let's
go I'm so pumped for that obviously card
cap to Sakura as well uh I don't know if
Emily watched card Captain Sakura or the
OG card cap
uh which I count as a different show
that is a different show yeah what
what's the difference uh because it was
dubbed for America and it kind of did
you hear about the one piece four kids
dub controversy at all well when they
changed like like
animation it's just yeah which which
controversy we talking yeah there's a
lot okay just the just the fact that
exists yeah I remember I remember
because I watched one piece uh on
Cartoon Network and I remember that the
like it they' change all like the
weapons to like toy weapons Sanji
doesn't smoke cigarettes he eats
lollipops I remember that too it goes
more than that they changed all of the
music to resemble more like Saturday
morning cartoons so all the original
soundtrackers gone best anime opening
ever they changed characters to be hey
hey Wacky I'm going to say a pun kind of
like character uh so they basically
changed the entire Vibe and everything
about the show um and I wouldn't say
card caps was on that same level of
changes but there definitely was a hell
of a lot of changes uh I mean they
changed the names of the characters uh I
think Sakura is the same cuz it's card C
Sakura I think her best friend they
changed her name to
Madison Madison yeah they changed her
name to Madison her real name I can't
remember because I'm not going to lie C
is [__] Madison I'm not going to lie
that dog looks like it's fan art
inserted into that picture it does F
like Sal it doesn't it doesn't look real
it does look like a piece of furry it
looks like it's she been put in
there My OC with Sakura like why like
what is that is that
Madison no Madison's the blackhair chick
yeah yeah know yeah yeah well I forgot I
forgot what his name was now I haven't
seen card cap in so godamn long I'll be
I'll be honest I remember more about
cards in Japan there seems to be these
shows that are more aesthetic shows and
this seems to fall into that where I see
a lot of people who like more so the
aesthetic than the actual show itself
well card Captain sakro was is written
by clamp who made some of the most like
you know visually aesthetic shows of
that kind right so like everything clamp
made was just like oh my God this looks
so pretty cuz like when I ask people you
know who really like the show I'm like
why do you like it they're like I just
love the like aesthetic and I love the
the vibe of it as opposed to it's got a
great story yeah I I remember the vibe
of card cap Sakura I don't remember oh
yeah her name was tomoyo tomoyo oh oh
and it became mad Madison
Madison hey Madison wait so was was that
is out of pocket so did they change all
the character names no I think Lee they
didn't change because Lee there's you
know just say is the same KIRO was his
name KIRO yeah K I guess kobos was too
long carab baros was too long kiss on S
it was KIRO I think they changed they
changed his
her brother's name as well so it's not
Yuko um so like
John Sakura and Clive I like how they
just kept Sakura cuz it was like Sakura
Sakura Sakura beautiful go uh C Captain
Sakura dub character names here we go
okay let's see let's see let's see what
do we got Sakura Avalon instead of
Sakura kimoto Sharon Lee is Lee Shon oh
my God okay carob is still car okay
that's good Tomo is Madison
Taylor Toya kinoto is Tori Avalon okay
okay Yuko is Julian
star what the [__] okay me Lee is Meen
Ray What the fu why what why why that
change that makes no sense whatsoever
Ariel hiiragizawa is Eli Moon
what the [__] yeah they didn't change
n's name though Ruby Moon Leila McKenzie
K mizugi is Leila McKenzie bro well yeah
that's is
Chelsea oh my
God oh my God why would you do that
Zachary God back back in the day of
English localizing dubs oh we Wang is
still we Wang we Wang yeah they're like
that's that's just a banger that's a
banger name we Wang is so Wang is a
banger name we're not changing thato is
just Maggie Maggie what the actual
[__] oh my God so I'm interested I'm
assuming she would have watched the dou
of card capts uh because that was the
thing that a on TV back in the day my
God that's so funny of course yeah n Joe
is there um Cafe with her it's awesome
yeah n has still been meaning to watch
so funny still been meaning to watch
that I know it's so goed and everyone
talks about how amazing it is I just
need to watch it I mean it it's like the
obviously the comedy is always
subjective so like a lot of I know a lot
of people who don't really understand
the comedy of nio because they just
don't really like the kind of L random
subverting expectations kind of humor
but what makes the show so good is just
Kyo animations just work on it it's so
aesthetically beautiful so impressive
and expressive and they managed to like
hold on to's like manga art style as
well like the manga looks exactly looks
very unique yeah I'm surprised n Jo
hasn't been like maybe it came out too
early or maybe not enough people watched
it I think it was ahead of his time but
it was it's the perfect meme reaction
show oh yeah you know to the point where
I'm surprised I don't see more meme
reactions of just nio characters you
know totally um yeah uh or monat as well
my love story I only watched was there
only one season of that I can't remember
yeah I believe so
um it was it was all I guess it was it
was all it was it was all it was good C
that character just looks like how Emily
draws herself I mean that's a very
common theme with Emily favorite shows
like Emily wishes kicking this no I
don't do that Emily wishes she was Torah
from Fruits Basket bro that that is
Emily yeah this is this this is just
hello I'm a clut main character energy I
the one scene I remember from my love
story is just the scene where she I
don't know she's running off for
something and then she trips over and
then she just and then they they show
her tripping over and she's just lying
flat on the ground just like dead just
like dead I was like what why did they
have to put that scene in I don't know
yeah I did think all those character
types were made up until I met Emily and
I was like wait people are actually this
clumsy and clsy yeah because I know
exactly why she put uh uh [__]
konosuba in as well because Aqua is yeah
yeah is Emily with blue hair Tokyo Mumu
I guess you know you just grw up on that
stuff it's a solo magical girl show um
and yeah uh kaguya summer is just a
really [__] good show just you know
in general it is the modern like
equivalent of that first romance anime
that this new generation is going to
look back on totally and think hey what
like what would you say is the kagio
summer of Our Generation romance school
days school days no I'd say oh well
because like I don't know was there a
romance comedy like Kya summer that came
out cuz like I feel a lot of the romance
shows that we look fondly over I feel it
was Tora yeah but like I was going to
say Tora but like it's not the same Vibe
right cuz K summer definitely espe I
don't think it has to be exactly the
same VI I just talking romance in
general big
romance because here's here's the
trajectory every like a lot of anime
fans take right which is you discover
anime through one of the main stream
show maybe it's probably Naro back in
the day and then you're like oh wait
there are things there are anime about
things that aren't people punching each
other and then there's always like that
one guy or that one friend who
recommends a romance anime for you to
watch and I feel like in this day and
age it is kagios Sama uh in our
generation it' probably be tororo
because that one guy was probably like
don't worry there's some actual Epic
action scenes in toora I feel like it
was either Toradora or Clan ad does clad
count as a romance I'm not sure yeah
totally it's just the slowest Romance of
all [__] time it's also one of the
most depressing romances of all time as
well part two part two is just
depressing cuz you're like [__] talk
to each
other uh yeah and uh yeah I mean what
else can we say about this all of these
romances is the kind of romances that
Conor absolutely despises as well yeah
yeah these are all romances I would
despise I mean the only one you kind of
like is panting stocking I [__] with
panting stocking a lot yeah koruba you
like right I love koruba yeah and you
like KAG summer I haven't watched KAG
summer oh okay I think you'd like kagio
summer I don't think you would like k no
no why not well because kagio Summer has
a lot of Comedy elements to it which I
think he might find that he can't look
past the high school element of that
yeah the high school element is
frustrating okay it's the the entire
like a lot of the comedy revolves around
it's idea of them being the student the
student council right I [__] hate
student council
like I I know Conor I'm like he'll hear
high school he like okay maybe maybe I
could look past it he'll see student
counsel who was like all I'm out I'm out
I'm out why is the student council in in
Japanese anime have more power than the
[__] presidency they they somehow can
get [__] done because that's what
Japanese high school kids wish in their
head that's how they Envision it in
their head cuz that's all they know I
don't know a power fantasy you know all
right but yeah uh this was very typical
of Emily good job uh let's good job em
good job Emily for you know fulfilling
your stereotypes let's go on to the next
one next one well good thing to know
that we do indeed know our friends uh
yeah we're pretty good at this yeah
we're four for four so far yeah four for
four oh I know who this
is oh I think I know who this is as well
yeah I know who this is yeah I know who
this is wait hold on yeah oh oh yeah
yeah my bad my bad yeah wait what we
have three people left shindo syney and
Kaho one of them doesn't make sense but
I'm pretty sure the rest is all right
wait no this one's I actually don't know
this
one this could be any of them no really
yes I know who this
is okay should we go in 3 2
one okay I'm going to take a guess okay
ready 3 two one Sydney okay um Anana and
Oro yeah okay I I looked at like Aken
kamakani like anohana or what the [__]
is that Aken I just saw that why does
everyone have the most giant tits aen is
a one of the worst anime ever made B one
of the funniest shows because it's just
so bad so so I I remember so the reason
I know this was because she obviously
told me to this uh told me uh the shows
to put on uh I noted down some things
about why they're on there as well
because oh she was saying something this
shot see she was saying some of this
[__] the the first show she says is
Naruto and I'm like I I've been with you
for 10 years we are married now I didn't
even know you watch Naruto I I was yes I
I was I think she was just trying to
please her husband with she was like
what the [__] you've watched Naruto
Sydney we've been married and she was
like yeah uh this was this was her first
anime uh and it was the very first time
she felt Goosebumps watching uh watching
any Shonen or any show in
she talks about the rock Le versus gar
fight and I'm
like excuse me how how have you never
talked to me about this you've never
referenced taking off the weights yeah
you've never referenced taking off the
weights you know you you clown on
everyone who watches Naruto and uh and
uh so that was the biggest kind of like
surprise for me so aen what what is this
show about other than big tits so aen is
a show from the early 2000s and one or
two episode OVA if I remember correctly
yeah um and it's uh said in high school
yeah um and it is one of the most
overtly over sexualized overreacted just
like comedy shows guess imagine if uh
fan service characters were some
lovecraftian nightmare
creatures that's aen because you look at
their like you look at their tits and
it's it's like it's it's it goes Beyond
not even knowing how the female anatomy
works yeah it's it's I just remember the
character the the the character with
like literally the biggest pair of tits
I've ever seen in my life like it's like
the size of her entire body yeah and
they are they go full jiggle physics
with it J scene yeah uh and uh Sydney
told me that this is on there because
this is the very first etchy show that
she watched this this this was the very
first ety show that she watch stumble
across this I never even heard of this
show because this what this is such an
Infamous show yeah because this show got
Infamous because of the tits like you go
on like any forums and someone would
have a like some sort of like gift of
one of the girls with her tits [__]
flopping about I I want to check this
out on YouTube please watch any scene
from and you'll be like what the [__] is
going definitely going to get age
restricted if we show any Clips on here
but she told me that this was the first
etchy show she ever watched and she was
and she was so terrified that her dad
would find out what she was watching
that she literally system rebooted her
entire computer after watching
aen I mean you know that's a great
[__] choice you know I I would I
would I think I would just smash my
computer with a hammer what the [__]
yeah yeah which scene are you watching
there just like the boobs are like
sentient things
yeah yep yep that's the scene that's the
scene I remember that is the scene has
the scene I remember what the heck I was
going to make a video on this show years
ago and I was like I don't think I can
without getting like [__] Community
guidelines stried for showing anything
okay see I looked at this 3x3 and the
reason why I got confused is because of
Bob same here bro same I have I had I
[__] love bobao and Sydney and I have
never talked about bobao Sydney's never
mentioned this to me either what the
[__] no way she's watched Bubba Bell
yeah she [__] when when she that was
actually was the second thing she said
after Naruto she was like Naruto B cuz
uh yeah those Bo I don't [__]
know do not put disrespect on my man's
name I I don't [__] know man it is
one of the funniest manga series I've
ever read I'll be I'll be honest I
haven't seen it it was it's so [__]
funny so what was her reasoning for
putting it on list uh that it was Naruto
and
Bobo of however did it say it the m b b
b uh those were like just her two
childhood animes it was huge on Cartoon
Network I remember like the dub was
really popular overseas yeah I think
Naruto and bobao I didn't know this
because in England we did not get bobao
at all at all uh so Naruto I knew about
but I didn't know that was like widely
spread on television as well yeah um
Bobo is just the most like if you took
every kind of poo poo pee PE humor and
throw it into a I think I think the I
think the original manga was like almost
30 CH 30 volumes um but it is oh my God
like this is still to this day one of
the most absurd yet hilarious comedy
shows and the and the anime as well is
really [__] funny as well yeah
obviously Orin High School Host Club
that checks out that that is like that
checks out hello I have just it I have
just discovered my first uh shjo anime
Anana checks out I think I've heard
Sydney seen the ending more than I've
actually heard the actual ending do you
think bring up anah a lot yeah yeah do
you think anah would have aged well at
all um oh that's a good
question uh I watched it and when I
watched it I was like this is a show
that I never ever want to watch again so
I'll never find out I just I just never
wanted to watch it again I mean I for
one if I needed if I needed to cry I
would put on anah yeah I for one [__]
loved this show when I watched it uh cry
like a baby at the end beautiful music
as well opening and ending Banger um I
don't know if I would recommend it to
people today though I know right it's
hard I think I think it's really like I
think people who watch it now some
people will like really [__] connect
to it and then others will be like this
is so cheesy I'm scared to rewatch it
because I hold it really really close to
my heart it's it's the the vibe of the
show is everything that I love but at
the same at the same time I think back
to it and I'm like a lot of this a lot
of the crying the sad part of the
aspects just feels really cheap like
here let me play this really sad song
when I want you to cry and it worked it
worked it like conditioned us like we
were a [__] dog to be like okay you
hear the Bell or you cry now you cry
what I would recommend instead I think
instead of anaana is uh Maria the the
mov yeah because that's written by the
same person and I think Maria is just I
think is is the better aged version of
anohana God do you know what I think
would be interesting cuz I was I had
this thought the other day where you
take a show like anah or some other
really popular show uh and you do kind
of like an after Story of all of the
characters grown up right and just
seeing just seeing where like I I think
K can you pull up the anohana 10 years
later like they did they did a 10 years
later drawing and I I saw it and I'm
like oh just give me like just give me
one like a Side Story I don't know if
I'm ready for this look look at this
look at this look at that poster oh my
God cck
yeah no click on the close up my
babies can we see a can we see a closeup
of this man beard he's got a
beard oh my God no no oh my no broke
down into a hippie man look at the main
character yo the guy on the left is me
for
real I oh I wasn't ready for that
they're like they're like salary men bro
yeah I know right in the fields man oh
that's just I will say like the [__]
bluehair girl like be careful you who
you make fun of in high school man be
careful of who you make fun in high fun
of in high school should an anime from
this age would have been more
interesting yeah I mean there's still
hope you know they might remake it who
knows yeah hopefully I mean I mean I
would I would not necessarily anaana but
I would love to see something like this
in general uh especially because all we
get is like the [__] what if official
collaboration pieces or what if fan arts
uh but I would love to see something
like that because I think that would be
absolutely incredible um all right going
back to the 3X3 though here's another
question I had for Sydney higashi now on
this 3x3 it's the recent remake
readaptation of it should have been the
original
origal put okay okay I wanted to ask are
we talking about the original hiashi
yeah um I mean checks out she she loves
her horror so this is not surprising at
all and there is not a lot to pick from
for it's the most solid entry I'd say
the original one for sure yeah I can see
this one this is always the first horror
anime that got spread around just
because it was like so shocking that Q
girls could actually you know it's a
cutesy art style but actually they're
all murderous girls and there's blood
and there's G and it has one of the most
convoluted stories ever written in
horror yeah yeah yeah I never I've never
finished the second season of higashi
which I know yeah no I liked it I
thought it was too slow really yeah in
the first season is too slow too I mean
I've played the original visual novel
and that is way slower than the anime so
yeah that's a that that attracts a
certain kind of person you know what's
good though the higashi manga is
actually I think more terrifying than
the anime because what they did with the
higashi manga which I really like cuz
you know how higar is split up into like
different sections I guess in the story
so what they did in the manga was each
section is actually illustrated by
different mongr oh that's actually kind
of so each section yeah so you actually
when you go through each section you
actually get completely different
visuals and different interpretations of
that part of the story and some of them
are some of the most terrifying manga
panels I've ever I cannot think about
the show without that scene from that
documentary where the guy's like yeah
today I researched how much gas it would
take to blow up a school why what no
no where is this documentary on YouTube
following I think like the family that
was like making the visual novel game if
you go to YouTube Type in like uh
Higurashi documentary it's actually a
pretty cool documentary just following
the family that makes it right and uh
yuk 7 right yeah yeah yeah and uh I
don't know if it's all dedicated to it
but there is like one scene where the
old guy I I swear he looks at his PC
yeah he turns around he goes well today
for accuracy I had to I had to figure
out how much gas it would take to blow
up a school for one of the scenes and I
was like I don't I don't I don't think
you had to research that well you needed
to make it realistic right I was like
did that have any bar ing on the plot
was like a question like was like how
much gas should we buy guys oh yes yes
officer that's that's why being an
author is just the best way to how many
views give yourself 629 629 VI how the
[__] did you find that it was um I think
it's been reuploaded a bunch it's an NHK
program from 2005 there's no way they
uploaded in 60 FPS in 2005 I know what
the [__] why did they do that yeah they
basically followed him and there's a
seam where he's like the old man yeah I
think it's this one yeah can you play it
from here yeah yeah I think it's like
around here the father who wants banned
games is in charge of background
research for one game I had to research
and chart volcanic gas
composition and for another I had to
figure out how much gas was needed to
blow up a
classroom I literally I literally cannot
think about this show without just
imagining an old man Googling how much
gas it takes to blow up classroom I'm
surprised getting on some government
list I'm surprised I remembered that
exact what the exact scenario God and I
just I have no idea hey man they had to
make sure it could be a real because
remember higar you do not need to
measure that you hiashi is a mystery
horror has to be realistic how did he
calculate that I don't
know I'm sure there on tan probably yeah
dude I I just can't reddit reddit figure
it out there's going to be someone in
the subreddit on this episode but being
like I figured out the gas composition
and how much you need
neededa being like depends on the size
of how did you research that tell me
like like okay did you really need to
research that I don't know I've never
once seen an explosion a piece of media
and thought no no there wasn't enough
gas doesn't seem right hey man some
authors want the believability of their
story to be watertight but it's just the
fact that it's the whole family
producing it and it's the father it's
just the old this old man who's just
sitting there looks Dead Pan on the
camera today I had to research how to
blow up a school it's a dead it's a dead
pan voice over that [__] kills me
yeah it's so good so good it's so
[__] funny but yeah good choice I
think for a horror anime um what on
Earth is this uh
Kam Kam I've heard Sydney talking about
this I've never seen it myself all I
know this is like a Saturday Night Live
parody of anime yeah the eyes are so
monstrously big is that there is one
seene or one uh clip uh screenshot that
got really really M and it's the one
where it's like search up search up kich
Mar Karen eyes and I'm sure it's got to
be I know which one you're talking about
yeah yeah where she looks like a [__]
bug
where
that's yeah I see this wait this this
looks like my drawings of characters
everybody thinks this is an edit but
this is actually in the episode the
episode because this is what the sty was
in the early 2000s the [__] this is the
uh mid 2000s how to draw anime art book
yeah oh there's also Cannon as
well what the [__] is the plot of the
show I don't even know I think it's some
kind of magical girl show from of it it
looks like a magical girl show
13-year-old Cy Hana feels like her life
can't get any worse parents died when
she was young Jes that was not how I
thought the show leaving her with an a
who doesn't hesitate to call her stupid
unless and useless over her paor gra God
damn uh her only friend her cat named
Xian passed away recently oh my God bro
she can't catch a break uh begins her
moment uh moment her life turns around
for the better when she is approached by
a girl who also has lost her parents and
her cousin who finds girls to be
Troublesome both of them searching for a
goddess her mother's momento ring brings
shines brightly in their presence and
fills her with its Radiance making you
smarter faster and capable of granting
wishes okay so it's like a mega
depressing magical girl spin I guess
godamn so why does why does uh Sydney
like I I don't know she uh so what the
[__] explain why she lies so that leads
into evangelon right I no but uh well
evangelon is how you guys met right
evang gilon is how we met but also she
actually watched it because uh I showed
it to her and uh it really really
[__] connected with her I mean
it's a legendary for a reason yeah so I
would say Karen I don't know like I've
talked to her a lot about K Karen she
she just holds it close to her heart
this this must be like that that one
nostalgic you know guilty pleasure show
that you grew up with you know it's not
the best but you have a special place
true with it which is fair all right
very fun list either way very fun well
now I know next time I see a Sydney I'm
going to talk to her about B we have
Kaho or shindo Al okay let see okay so
here's the second or last one that we
have uh I'm pretty confident wow I am
pretty confident I think I am also
confident no actually [__] this could be
either Kaho or
shindo oh [__] actually you're right
you're right kah or Sho con it's like a
mixture of what I think the two of them
were like Macross Frontier so we have
mac so we have digim Digimon Adventures
we have isaki quartet we have some show
I've never seen vampire dies in nose
time which is quite a recent one if I'm
not mistaken neon J Evangelion Arab Arab
sa uniform maluka magika oh what is that
middle one at the bottom there I've seen
that before and it's in her
circumstances oh yes you're right and
macros Frontier yeah [__] um I think I
no actually it's it's literally I I I
was I was confident and then I looked at
some of them and I'm like wait I'm
leaning more towards
shinder but some of these choices could
be is also Kaho okay I'm pretty sure I'm
going to say shindo I I think it's Kaho
I think it's Caro really I remember
brought up to me Macross more than
anyone else ever in my life K Kaho has
brought up Macross uh in the first
podcast that we recorded I remember she
loves Macross and I believe I remember
talking to her about Digimon as well she
does like
Digimon digim otherwise I would I would
have been like oh this is shindell right
yeah yeah that makes sense all right who
who is it oh all right okay wow this is
such an in what is that top right one
medier nud it says oh nud sorry I don't
think it's me oh God Pak it looks like
maybe 80s early '90s maybe yeah so Kaho
has watched an ungodly amount of anime
yeah uh I didn't fully appreciate this
when we first had K on when she started
bringing up fake weebs and I was like I
thought she just meant like some people
watch like two anime but I think she
means like 90% of people who watch anime
cuz Kaho has watched so much anime yeah
uh and her knowledge of it is very
impressive so this this looks like a
very varied list very varied and I
wonder why I've always wondered why Kaho
likes Digimon so much she actually did
give me reasonings though oh she did she
did yeah it's cuz it's the superior
Pokemon how [__] dare okay well is
there one you'd like to know about first
I can I can what is the top right one
what is that the top right one okay ran
okay let me scroll up okay here we go I
have I have the list um it is is
it I've never seen it before it looks
like a show CH sailor uniform no no
that's a different one no no that's
that's the one on the midle uh
um akazukin Chacha akazukin
Chacha I've seen this around but I have
no is this like a really OG shjo anime
look at that second picture there that
is that is OG shjo manga [__] says
capturing the mesmerizingly cute art
from anime the show manages to hold both
Sayo Vibe and Yuri fan service it's a
gem wow say so and Yuri there say so wow
wow uh okay I've never seen it or heard
of it but this is OG this is very when
did it come out can you can you go
Wikipedia this must have been pretty old
um K was also mentioned to 1994 yeah K
mentioned to me in the past that she
really likes a lot of ovas yeah
um I mean the '90s was the [__] Peak
OVA Peak OVA I mean I do kind of miss
the
OVA era of anime just because you had so
many interesting and different [__]
ideas that didn't always appeal to the
mainstream masses but they would be able
to be Mage just because it was like a
three episode OV well we'll never get
like another genocyber or like violence
Jack or any of those yeah I was talking
to C about it and I was like yeah I
really want to watch more '90s ovas I
can't remember I watching a show like a
random show from the '90s and the show
did not call for it at all but randomly
like 5 minutes in just titties and like
naked and like it wasn't brought up in
like a sexual way it was just titties
and then just moved on I was like no
sensor bar either nothing and I was like
okay wow geez we really doing this if
you want to see anime in its roest form
then just watch a bunch of 90s yeah
everything was weird that's that's the
point it didn't really matter about
appealing to kind of like writing like a
mainstream story people just had weird
[__] ideas that's why it's so
fascinating to go down that rabbit hole
cuz just find some of the wildest
stories and not everything is a banger
uh not everything is like the best
written story but you will have a very
unique time yeah you will see some very
unique things yeah it's it's been fun
I've been watching what did I watch one
called key the metal Idol have you heard
this one I have not [__] weird it's
basically like people who are trying to
make
uh robots that are that you can pilot
via humans but to to Pilot it you need
to take the like soul out of someone and
it's just this weird it's so weird and
it's like 15 episode OVA and it's all
got it's like titties all the time is
this on Netflix no no I just found it it
looked weird and I was like I'll [__]
watch it yeah all of these you just have
to find online some and it's like way
too dark for no reason it's like a I
kind I kind of [__] this I [__] with
this 90 stuff oh you're going through
your metal phas so I'm kind of having a
fun time it's fun just watching these
random shows that are I don't I don't
think they're good or bad I just think
they're weird they just fascinating and
i' I've been trying to find shows that
have no pre-existing manga and this show
was all just original o weird it's so
weird yeah totally um I mean I think for
me aa and Moka ma Ross and Digimon make
a lot of sense uh you know a KB sailor
uniform that was I never saw that one
that came out recently uh it came out
like two years ago three years
ago when did it come out oh wait
sorry oh sorry sorry
sorry the description I gave was for
sailor uniform capturing me
mesmerizingly cute art from the managed
to hold
SE [__] what actually said about
akazuki and chaa is this is one of the
most differently adapted anime from the
manga in 1994 adding magical girl theme
which the original didn't have at all it
totally worked wow okay okay and then
Kaho liked the Yuri and Sayo Vibes of AK
Chan yeah cuz I was I was uh going to
say that this this came out yeah last
year okay it wasn't it wasn't too long
ago two years ago actually two years ago
K's reasoning for Digimon shut the [__]
up shut the [__] up Joey kah's reasoning
for Digimon is the best thing i' ever
heard in my life what so the reason why
K likes has put Digimon on this list she
said I was a student at a Protestant
school I stopped going to church on
Sunday morning for this show and chose
and chose My Religion
[Laughter]
anime B kaho's English is so good that
Kaho used a
semicolon in a correct way in a correct
way I what the [__] my god I've never
used a semicolon I think one time I used
it had a quadruple check I used it right
I always get the green like
squiggly in my word dog it's like I
don't need to use this do I use a colon
or a semicolon here stop going to
Protestant school and chose My Religion
ad hell yeah that's so good yeah I mean
I think Digimon I mean I being being a
digimon fan myself it was I don't know
it was what I thought people found in
Pokemon which is you you had your
animals and [__] like that uh but to me
Digimon just had a more engaging
storyline to me no totally I mean I
watched both uh I enjoyed both Digimon
and Pokémon um I like as you said I like
Pokémon for completely different
different reasons to Digimon um Pokemon
is just like heroin of nostalgia yeah
yeah Pokemon is just like turn your
brain off good fun times whereas Digimon
is actually like an engaging story yeah
it has it has a engaging narrative even
for it you know for it Target
demographic until that is until Pokemon
gives you the [__] Butterfree episode
then you're like all right real [__]
real [__] only men cry to this [__] and
the Charizard episode the leading
forward meme oh Charizard the Charizard
episode [__] me up uh K says for evang
gallion this show made anime more
meaningful to a lot of adolescents even
contributed to forming new categories
like suere and chuni yeah yeah I don't I
don't know what is chuni chuno is like
the the Trope where it's like you think
you have magical powers but you actually
don't you know know that uh and then K
says you just cannot ignore the impact
oh yeah I mean aonami Ray is the reason
why kou [__] exist like she there are
so many and Asar is the reason why tund
are so popular uh isai quartet I thought
I thought it was rezero but I only just
sawart says basically like Avengers or
Justice League of isekai shows but
turning them into Chibi characters and
making them go to school together could
this be more anime the comedic chaos
works so insanely well uh even even made
a movie with solid story yeah I I
enjoyed eai quartet enough just because
hey this is an insane idea let's just
put a bunch of different characters from
different IPS and let's see what happens
yeah I think the only reason why I liked
it is because all of the isai characters
that are in it are from isai I actually
enjoy yeah
the like I like I like cor I I like
rezero Tanya was was good enough you
know so I'm just like all right yeah all
right cool yeah it was like a nice
little fun show it was like to me it
more felt like fan service than an
actual oh totally than a natural show
you know something like the Avengers
you're like this kind of like built up
to this massive narrative point where
all of these different characters coming
together this just more felt like hey
it's it's a nice like what if fan
service show where they all come
together um so it was enjoyable what did
she say about the vampire dies in no
time that's also re uh vampires die
vampire dies in no time the Mis
stupidity and comf in is superb in this
comedy also voice fits each character so
perfectly including the singing part it
generally captures the original manga
while making it more colorful and fun I
I don't know this show actually seen I
saw before this show uh like first
couple of episodes but um I've heard
from a lot of people that this is
actually a really solid show like solid
comy show I knew k would bring out the
uh more the left hookers yeah yeah the
shows that we hadn't seen as much
because Kaho has just watched so many
one one thing that I'm very happy with
is that uh she's watched his and her
circumstances and it's been so long
since if if you're talking about a
romance anime that brings back pure
Nostalgia for me it is his and her
circumstances which which show is this
bottom bottom what's the Japanese title
of that cuz there's a show called
K uh this was a mass piece of G gyx with
ano uh it's also ano as well and you can
tell cuz the the ending is whack as [__]
the ending is a whack of [__] with cool
Transitions and pacing of its own the
show exemplifies one of the rare times
when I prefer watching anime over
reading manga of the same title for the
animation greatly helps you be
emotionally invested was it was it Kor
used a bunch of music from AA or was it
the other way around I think they both
use music from each other each other
shows right yeah I guess you've made a
banger just why not know well he
directed uh Shin Godzilla as well and he
just straight up uses the the
iconic in like the planning scene and
and I'm like wait hold on hold on a
second ano 2.0 OST is the kako OST yeah
huh yeah so ano is just like like yo we
made it I'm a recycle I'm a recycle is
it even the same uh genre it doesn't
matter doesn't matter we're going to
we're going to reuse it uh I asked K
about M magika she says everything about
M magic is unique art style music and
more importantly story considering a lot
of bait and switch shows came after this
the anime was so evolutional that it
made a trend yeah I mean like maduka
magika was kind of the reason why the
whole like deconstruction of genres
thing he started the deconstruction
Trend and then everyone's like wait a
minute does anyone know what
deconstruction actually means and then
everyone's like wait we just been using
that word I don't know making parodies
we got to think about this it's like
when people finally realize they didn't
know what the word sakuga meant yeah
it's just like we're just using it
because it sounds cool and then ma Ross
C says not only uh the songs by yokoo
were bangers the romantic and
professional battle between two girls
was well written plus the fact the boys
boy in the love triangle was a career
focused pilot who had a pretty face with
the career background of playing a
female lead in Kabuki gave him more
depth than the typical why does he get
to be popular dudes in har she's she's
more in depth than like 95% of her the
show was catchy in so many ways yeah it
was I mean yeah it was good I mean
matross that was like legendary for a
reason that was legendary for his time
legendary in Japan as well legendary 4
its genre it it was also kind of like a
[__] monkey porw I guess because I
think we have matross to thank for Idols
yeah oh God first ever anime Idol was in
m it was it was a Mecca show originally
a Mecca show and there was an idol in it
and then everyone was like wait we
really like this Idol story line and uh
and now we have and here we are how many
years later now we haveb and and now and
now they're like wait what if we just
removed the meccas and just keep the
idols right yeah damn what could go
wrong and now we have vtubers akb48
pushed their glasses up and was like we
know what to do I feel under qualified
to even rate C's list I feel like C's
list is is probably good it is yeah it's
it's solid um and very C for sure all
right let you want to check out this
last one let's check out shindo uh I
wonder if they've kept it for last cuz
it's weird yeah let's find out I have no
clue what he could have put on just just
look at this be the most all right here
we go ooh oh oh wow wow this is not what
I would have expected this is not what I
expect oh God there's a lck of [__] up
stuff God he's got some [__] good
shows here bro all right so Ghost in the
Shell uh JoJo starus Crusaders record of
Loos SW [__] Bast G Lagan Evangelion
NAA mushishi eslon and Attack on Titan
[__] yeah F yeah I [__] with it dude
mushishi and esaf Nas on here so good
excuse me Gan Lagan as well yeah
obviously do yeah I'm not I'm not
counting I'm not counting like Jojo
Gillan a and uh very much I like he put
Ghost in the Shell but Standalone
complex uh which is to me the best Ghost
in the Shell um so it yeah dude big
props for [__] mushishi though that
that is still in my opinion one of the
most underrated the most Joey anime of
all time it is one it's such an
underrated anime it's so good of the the
anime equivalent of lighting a
blonde I mean kind of
yeah I I've I've never I've only it's
just going off Clips I've SC of the show
is the equivalent of like it's kind of
more the equivalent of like you know
smoking out of a pipe yeah you're a
little bit fania no but mushishi is I I
still think visually it was so
incredibly ahead of its time um and the
story is just so [__] captivating
it's it's so good and the manga is
amazing as well yeah it's it's a great
show um I just I it's funny looking back
on mushishi and just like knowing Joey
as a mate I look at Mishi and I'm like
this is this is this is everything that
capsules Joey as a vibe in there y you
know if if you know this could be a
[__] album cover or something you
know and uh dude mushishi manga covers
our album cover they're so aesthetic
what is record I I mean I know what it
is but what is record of lotus War about
record of lotus war is oh God when did
it when did it come out [__] '90s ' 80s
think it's '90s '90s right yeah it came
out
let me see records of lotus
Wars
1990 okay well I was technically right
what was the show about it's a about a
Lotus War isn't it yeah have you seen it
I haven't seen it I don't remember have
you seen it gone I haven't oh okay so
none of us have seen this so we yeah I
I've heard about the show it's weirdly I
have seen it I remember nothing about it
though store thank
you Creator from the op math of the last
great battle of the gods lotos and his
kingdoms have been plagued by War for
thousands of years as a quiet peace and
unity finally see uh became foreseeable
over the land an unknown evil being uh
begins to stir an ancient witch has
awakened bent on preserving the island
of lotos by creating political unbalance
throughout the many kingdoms and keeping
anyone from maintaining central control
s like a political there is a certain is
it is it an
isekai no I think it's just a fantasy
fantasy is it okay I it's a political
fantasy because I have seen like uh a
lot of it kind of if it's kind of
nostalgic looking back at a lot of 9s
fantasy cuz n the '90s era of anime did
have a lot of fantasy and funny enough a
lot of EA as well it was just totally a
totally different vibe than what you see
in like the modern isekai uh landscape
right now a lot of the fantasy back then
was about these kind of like epics and
something more traditional some
something more in line with what you see
with like traditional Jr token kind of
like worldes yeah uh I think one of my
favorites was Three Kingdoms as well
that was a big fantasy that came out as
well what about um obviously what's the
one from the the now and now and then
here and now now and then here and there
um cuz he has another East gu Fantasy on
here as well uh I'm not sure I think
this is just a fancy but eSalon
ESL people forget that it is an eai it
is TE an isai just totally different
vibe I'm telling you there's so many
isai that came out in the 9s right it
was just it was just totally different
he wasn't seen as bottom of the barrel
entertainment it would it was just more
classic kind of like n they were better
at hiding the concept maybe maybe it's
just the people who grew up with those
are now working and the ones making all
these damn stories cuz they were so
inspired by stuff like Esa I mean
technically you know inas is an isai
inash is an isai yeah which everyone
forgets I I think the big difference is
that nowadays isai is used as kind of
like a mechanic to gets the main
character somewhere to a fantasy world
and the big difference is that the
protagonist always has no problem being
in the fantasy world but all of the '90s
e card that I remember all revolved
around hey how the [__] do I get back
home so I I have the reasonings uh for
some of these which is there any that
you guys want to hear about yeah I would
love to know records of lotus War okay
record of lotus War OG tolken DND anime
that lives rentree my soul there go uh
deed lit is best goal in everybody's
first elf
Crush I'd love to know why JoJo's on
there JoJo's Adventure OST alone makes
it one of the best ever uh Stardust
Crusaders is my favorite Stone ocean
best op barely beating bloody stream
bloody stream is [__] go bloody
bloody bloody stream isn't Stardust
though no bloody stream is uh battle
tendency battle tendency yeah
that is that the most [__] hype op
yeah all time fight me what about eSalon
eslon uh isekai before it was
cool okay okay uh fantasy mix great OST
uh fantasy mix he said fantasy mix
twice say no more fantasy mix mushishi
epitome of anime as Vibe uh characters
what I mean characters are so drenched
in sadness I can't help but love them
agreed okay uh NAA
NASA uh let's see uh Peak Miyazaki
fantastic storytelling with great
characters amazing and haunting OST
still waiting for AER adaptation huh
there is a manga adaptation isn't there
there isn't apparently oh [__] um even
gallion cuz he's another person Les
would love to know why Evangelion where
is it Evan is just simple how have you
felt depression this series is probably
on anybody's top five a genre in itself
perfect mix of edginess militarism toat
of nostalgia and emotional trauma Oscar
best hell yeah dare hell yeah that's how
that's how I knew he was a man of how
could you shinder only anime fans be
like yeah militarism some deep topics
also this this this girl's best
girl imagine that just sums up weebs
perfectly but yeah um I'm surprised of
the lack of I guess like you know like
uh sexual shows I am not I am not this
is like the free Ren thing
where you know if it's too in your face
then a lot of a lot of like artists or
fan artists that I've seen are just
aren't [__] interested cuz why why
would you there's no imagination there
there's no way you can take you know
there's no interesting thing you can
take that character that hasn't already
been presented yeah he does like he did
mention that he likes what is it like
like not looting but pushing the
boundary yeah like figuring out how take
it further this is it just does surprise
me that the guy who made Metamorphoses
likes mushishi
this just not a combination I thought
would work but I guess Mak sense I see
it cuz like I I feel like a lot of the
times I you know I'm sure reviewers we
talking to like different authors and
what they like sometimes you ask them
what kind of series you're into and it's
never the series you think it's going to
be yeah sometimes the most [__] up or
you know sometimes the authors that make
the most [__] up stories or sometimes
the most like I remember I remember when
shindo was on the show he said his
favorite manga was spy
family that was kind of of is like whoa
all right good on you I guess yeah I was
talking to
uh oh [__] V like yukimura Yuki makot
yukimura yeah and I was like so why why
do you want to do Vikings and
uh wait let me let me let me let me
remember the name there's this there was
this like Viking cartoon that inspired
him uh and you know inspired him to kind
of like make a Viking story outside of
just being
Vikings asterisk is it Vicki Vicki the
Viking he such a Vicki the Viking or
something like that Vicky the Viking oh
yeah animated series he showed me this
[__] and I was like what the
[__] you came say what this became mid
Saga this this inspired I have no
enies what what's next one punch Man
author watch C you growing
up it's pretty bizarre like you're like
well this is this is not the vibe I
thought he was going to be that is
awesome I love
that I mean he just seems very wholesome
in general he just seems very wholesome
in general which you know surprising oh
they had a live action apparently yeah
sometimes surprising when you see these
authors that do these Heavy Deep
piercing stories and then they're like
what you so what do you actually like
what you watch and they're like oh I
like spy family or I like Vick the it's
I'm sure it's I just like the fact that
Vicki had no
enemies I mean this looks like a show
where she does have no enemies like
legit you know it feels like it's like a
it's like when you like whenever you
find out any inspiration is so simple
you're like what it's like have you seen
that there's this like short that's
going around it's um I think it's when
the one of the gorillas artists he's
saying what how he got like the starting
of um oh I've seen this yeah and it's
the
preset play and it's just the entire
it's the rock one preset you're like
what that's how you can't you didn't
even cop that you heard it he just heard
that was like I'm just going to add a
wrap on yeah it was what is it it's uh
the clean Eastwood CLE Eastwood this is
clean Eastwood it's like and it's you're
like there's no way there's no way and
it's like same with like death punk
where you find out some of their some of
their songs some of the beats are just
straight up just other songs yeah wasn't
it it was like it was like a '90s Casio
keyboard that he bought at a garage sale
and he just like pressed the rock one
and it was literally just CL it's so
awesome got some Dam ALB what a j yeah
when that short became viral I'm sure
some audio audio engineer somewhere
around the world was like see that's
what I was been saying all of these
years buy out all the Casio keyboards
it's free range oh my God but yeah um
interesting pic Sho um yeah and uh I
guess great great pixel round
all around interesting stuff some some
clear favorites keep popping up death
not attack on Titan Evangelion um and z
z z impressive great music great music
what can I say oh yeah PR and I would
say nothing was too surprising as well
everything Sydney's was probably the
most surprising yeah I'd say so I think
she I think she I think it's because she
became more of a mangar reader a lot of
her anime kind of like represented the
[__] she watched when she was younger
and just stopped watching anime yeah
that's fair um cuz she showed me her
manga 3x3 and I'm like oh this is
um wait let me let me see let me see
what she put on a manga 3x3 why is is it
like a bunch of not very wellknown shows
or um it's just very Sydney okay so I'm
just going to name these out so kitchen
princess uh drops of God okay waku zake
monster okay Shiki yeah stargazing dog
never heard of that one uh it's it's a
it's a manga about a dog all right
that's okay say less say l it's a manga
about a dog this one this one was the
biggest one that surprised me onani
master kurasawa really yeah huh that's
that that was like mean that is a great
[__] manga that that was her most
surprising one so onani Master C
masturbation Master
C it's it's actually uh it's actually
really funny though okay no it's
actually like it's like an inel
Redemption story it's actually one of
one of the yeah it's actually one of the
hardest this was before like the inel
movement came out but it's actually a
story of a really really [__] up guy
and it's kind of like an inspiring
Redemption story of this like [__] up
incel um yeah a lot of these are just uh
cooking manga alcohol and uh cute dogs
I'm surprised which is Sydney I'm
surprised then she didn't put the shiky
anime on a 3X3 and instead decided to go
with hiashi uh she put the Shiki manga
yeah because she was like Shiki manga's
I mean way better it better for sure
yeah but that was all the 3X3 and guess
what guys if you are over on our patreon
patreon.com then we've actually released
a 3X3 where we go over the patron 3x3
anime and give our thoughts on it so if
you like to check it out hey here's a
little clip of it and you have [__]
legend of the galactic heroes which is
easily the best Space Opera Story Ever
Told and then you [__] have regular F
scho I'm just saying you know sometimes
you got to be true to yourself true he's
so you know you he likes incest every
time and if you'd like to be in the next
patreon video like this one then uh head
on over to our patreon patreon.com
trashtaste links in the description but
hey look at all these patrons all look
at all them right supporting the show
aming people what did you guys think of
our guest 3x3 let us know in the
comments and uh hey thanks for watching
guys if you want to support our show
patreon.com trashtaste also follow us on
Twitter send us memes on the subr if you
hate our Facebook listen to us on
Spotify and we will see you guys in the
next probably not anime related one cuz
we filled our quot up already all right
all right
[Music]
bye